Ich mag eigentlich den Ansatz, den du gefragt hast. Du kannst das Theater hacken. Wenn du am Morgen aufstehen bist, und du direkt ins Theater gehst, beginnst du, Sets zu schenken und die Lichter zu verbinden, dann hast du ein Theater hacken.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 172. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, heute ist mal wieder Spezialthema angesagt. Hab ich zumindest so im Gefühl. Ich weiß so recht noch gar keinen Titel, aber ich glaube, das wird sich so im Laufe des Gesprächs dann auch herausstellen. Erstmal geht es darum, so ein bisschen Hacker-Historie zu beleuchten und auch ein wenig die Gegenwart mal auseinanderzunehmen. Und das Ganze mal aus einer Perspektive, die wir hier sonst ein bisschen seltener haben, nämlich einer spezifisch holländischen Perspektive. Und dazu begrüße ich Rob, Rob Gonggrijp. Hallo. Ja, schön, dass du es mal geschafft hast. Das hat sich hier gerade ganz zufällig ergeben, hier in Berlin, in der Metaebene. Ja, Rob, du bist ja schon eine Weile dabei, kann man so sagen. Wann bist du denn in den Computertopf gefallen und hast so den Zaubertrank aufgenommen?
Also ich war schon mit Technik schon eine Weile unterwegs. Ich habe mit so elf angefangen, Sender zu bauen.
Radiosender.
Ich bin jetzt 42, also das war in 79 oder so, habe ich angefangen Radiosender zu bauen. Und mit zwölf hatten wir dann so einen echten Radiostation mit Sendungen und selber dann mit Kassetten und Musik und selber einen Mischpult bauen.
Echt, ihr habt richtig Radio gemacht.
Wir haben richtig Radio gemacht, so mit zwölf. Und dann waren wir mit, ich war glaube ich, ich war noch zwölf, dann waren wir in die Ferien in England und dann hat mein Vater, weil Freunde von uns das auch hatten, hat er einen ZX81 gekauft.
Der Gute.
Mit der Gedanke ist alles Englisch, du verstehst das zwar noch nicht, aber wenn wir zu Hause sind, dann erkläre ich dir das alles und dann kannst du vielleicht selber ein bisschen programmieren. Dann habe ich der Rest der Ferien eigentlich nichts anderes gemacht als dieses Handbuch tausendmal hin und her lesen, bis ich alles verstanden hatte.
Das heißt, dein Vater war auch schon mit Computern zugange?
Naja, mein Vater hatte dann erst später selber auch noch einen Computer, einen Tandy TRS-80 Model 100. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die noch erinnerst. Das sind so die ganz flache Notebook-ähnliche Computer mit 8 Regeln mit 40 Charakters.
Ja, das ist ja auch so ein Klassiker der Steinzeit.
Klassiker der Steinzeit. Mein Vater war Journalist bei einer großen Zeitung in Holland. Bevor er das hatte, hat er dann in die Zeitung angerufen und sein Artikel dann vorgelesen an der Steno-Abteilung. Und jetzt konnte er das selber mit Akustik-Modem rüberladen. Das war aber ein Jahr, nachdem ich schon den ZX81 hatte. Aber dann habe ich auch angefangen, als ich 13 oder 14 war, mit Modems zu spielen und Bulletin Boards. Mal gucken, ob man in den Uni-Computern anrufen kann.
81, 82?
So was, so um den Dreh.
Wie gut war es denn da in Holland bestellt, um die BBS-Bulletin Board-Mailbox-Szene?
Es gab, glaube ich, drei in ganz Holland am Anfang. Das war ein 300-Baud-Akustik-Koppler. Das muss man sich auch nicht sehr viel vorstellen. 1200-Baud-Full-Duplix war noch nicht da. Es gab eigentlich nur noch 300-Baud und diese 1275.
Was dann für BTX?
Was hier BTX hieß, bei uns Video-Text.
Feed-Itail, Entschuldigung.
In Holland war das auch so verbreitet. Wir waren da gar nicht bewusst. Also Frankreich, Minitail, Deutschland, Bildschirmtext.
Ja, bei uns war es kleiner. Aber das gab es dann. Also 300 Baut war das einzige, was man vor Luplex hatte. Ja, da angefangen zu spielen. Mit den drei Bulletin Boards war man dann irgendwann fertig.
Das hast du noch mit deinem ZX81 gemacht?
Nein, das war mit dem Tandiriteris 80x100, als mein Vater dann nicht zu Hause war. Denn der kam dann um sieben abends zu Hause. Und bevor diese Zeit konnte ich dann damit spielen. Da gab es auch noch ein paar Telefonrechnungen, die meine Eltern sich noch länger erinnert haben.
Oh Gott, das war ganz furchtbar.
Und da gab es dann noch mal die Phase, dass die Familie festgestellt hat, sie ist nicht mehr erreichbar von außen.
Weil die Telefonleitung die ganze Zeit belegt ist.
Diese Phase hatten wir glaube ich alle.
Und wie haben sie dann reagiert? Haben sie versucht zu verbieten oder haben sie dir eine eigene Telefonleitung gegeben?
Nein, eine eigene Telefonleitung zu Hause hatte ich nie. Ja, dann würde es ein wenig reguliert. Nur zwei Stunden oder nur innerhalb Amsterdam, wenn es mal wieder um etwas höhere Beträge ging.
Aber die anderen Boxen, BBSen, waren bestimmt auch in Amsterdam, oder?
Es gab zwei in Amsterdam, ja.
Das war schon so ein bisschen das Zentrum, oder? Das elektronische Kultur. Ich weiß nicht. Also ich meine, Amsterdam hat natürlich aus der Ferne betrachtet immer so einen besonderen Glanz. So ist die Stadt, die man primär mit den Niederlanden in Verbindung bringt.
Ja, gerade zu dem Zeit war das auch noch so. Mittlerweile ist auch Rotterdam richtig so ein Kulturzentrum am Werden. Aber zu dem Zeit war Amsterdam so richtig der Stadt. Da war auch viel los. Gerade so in 1980 war die Hausbesetzerbewegung richtig, richtig groß. Also auch als kulturelle Faktor und Faktor im öffentlichen Leben. Mir fährt gerade nichts ein.
Ja, also ok, also du hast halt mit diesen BBSen angefangen, als hattest du das auch gleich irgendwie programmiert oder war das jetzt wirklich von vornherein Kommunikation, die dich da begeistert hat?
Sowohl als auch, ich hab angefangen zu programmieren auf diesen ZX-81 in Basic und auch ein bisschen Z80 Machine Gold. Aber ich fand auf den BBSen auch diese Kommunikation interessant und wir haben da auch in Gruppen, so bei den ersten BBSen in Holland, Neops und Saga und wir haben da auch festgestellt, diese Kommunikation ist anders. Ich glaube, jeder entdeckt das, aber wir haben das auch, ich erinnere mich Gespräche, wo wir das dann in Gruppen von so 30, 40 Leute, die auf einem so einen BBS jeder Tag oder jede paar Tage da waren, weil das hatte nur zwei Leitungen oder ein oder zwei oder drei und da konnte man also, man war da einmal am Tag oder zweimal am Tag und hat dann reagiert.
Es waren mehr so Anrufbeantworter.
Es waren mehr so Anrufbeantworter, genau. Und diese 30, 40 Leute, die auf diesen BBSen da waren, haben, ich erinnere mich noch gut, dass wir untereinander festgestellt haben, hier ist was ganz anderes. Die Kommunikation sieht anders aus. Das wirkt nicht wie ein Gespräch. Es ist die Dinger, die wir jetzt alle wissen. Konflikte laufen schneller aus dem Ruder. Man muss da schon ein bisschen aufpassen mit so Ironie und ein bisschen freundlich zueinander sein. Andere Leute werden dominant im Gespräch. Es handelt sich vielmehr um die Argumente als um, wer das richtig schön präsentiert und wer immer das Gespräch irgendwie monopolisiert. Sondern es sind Sachen, die man erst später dann Kultur würden. Ich erinnere mich noch gut, dass wir das in 82 schon darüber geredet haben.
Da warst du ja eigentlich auch schon relativ früh dabei. Wie hat sich das so angefühlt, da so alleine zu sein mit so wenigen?
Ich erinnere mich erst die spätere Phase, als ich dann mal in den Medien war. Dann sind wir schon in 87, 88. Als es dann in Holland angefangen hat, so ein bisschen Interesse in dieses Thema zu kommen. Und dass auch Journalisten mal von Modems und Computern gehört hatten. Ich erinnere mich gut, dass ich damals in 1987, war ich 18, 19, dieses Versuch zu erzählen, dass wir da eine neue Welt entdeckt hatten. Und da sind allerhand Sachen los und da passiert viel. Und da ist jetzt Newsnet und Newsgroups und weltweite Kommunikation. Das wird die Welt ändern. Es wird nicht lange so sein, dass das mit Amerika kommunizieren so teuer ist, dass niemand das macht. So diese ganze Evangelismus, was wir da gemacht haben. Und das würde so in 87 echt noch mit Kopf schütteln. Die erste Gegenfrage war dann, und wie lange sitzt du denn pro Tag hinter diesem Rechner?
Die Frage kommt ja auch heute noch.
Ja, aber es würde nicht wahrgenommen als Entdeckung eine neue Welt. Es würde wahrgenommen als, ja hier ist aber einer komisch.
Die sitzen die ganze Zeit im Ketter vor dem Bildschirm.
Ja, aber auch so richtig nur als Human Interest interessant.
Und gar nicht so die eigentliche Botschaft.
Und gar nicht so die eigentliche Botschaft. Würde gar nicht wahrgenommen, dass das eine Botschaft war. Und dass das kam, dann sind wir schon über 1990.
Und ich würde sogar sagen, noch deutlich später, ne?
Na ja, obwohl das in Holland früher kam als hier in Deutschland.
Das stimmt. Also das war ja auch immer mein Eindruck, dass Holland in gewisser Hinsicht so auch die Speerspitze war, was die Internetverbreitung betraf. Und auch so die Akzeptanz der neuen Kommunikationsformen und Kommunikationswege. Das hat sich ja auch konkret daran gezeigt, dass eigentlich in Amsterdam später dann das Internet eigentlich das erste Mal so richtig aufgeschlagen ist. Sehe ich das eigentlich richtig?
Das siehst du richtig, aber teilweise sind das Zufallsfaktoren.
Also was ist denn passiert? Also wann hast du denn das Internet als solches? Gut, also Usenet hast du ja schon erwähnt. Das kam dann wahrscheinlich so Mitte der 80er Jahre dazu.
Mitte bis Ende, ja.
Und wann?
Zumindest, dass ich es wahrgenommen habe. Und dass es bei uns in der Szene eine Rolle spielte.
Ja, und habt ihr dann sozusagen das Usenet selber über den Teich geholt? Oder wurde es schon geholt?
Nein, nein, nein, das wurde schon geholt. In Amsterdam gibt es an der Uni, gab es immer schon, schon lange bevor ich da angefangen bin, so Anfang der 80er gab es da schon Connections mit Amerika. Piet Beertema, einer der Pioniere in Holland, der war schon in 1980 dabei, Computer zu vernetzen und da gab es dann auch eine Datenleitung nach Amerika. Ich glaube, der war Mitte der 80er schon 64 Kilobit und da gingen dann die ganze Tag Mail und UUCP und die ganze News, das ging da schon rüber und später dann auch IP.
Das war dann wiederum relativ früh, IP war dann auch schon Anfang der 90er Jahre. Ich weiß immer nur, in Holland war schon immer alles da, was in Deutschland dann immer erst später kam. In Deutschland ging das ja so los über Dortmund etc.
Man muss die Rolle von Xs4All und die ersten Provider, weil es gab noch ein paar, die ungefähr um die gleiche Zeit angefangen sind, auch nicht übertreiben. Weil an der Uni gab es dieses Internet schon lange und es war auch in 1993, als wir da mit Xs4All angefangen sind, da gibt es noch eine kleine Vorgeschichte, eigentlich 92. In 92 sind wir dann mit Hektiknetz, unser Zeitschrift, was es zu dem Zeitpunkt gab, sind wir dann online gegangen und das online war dann Mail und News, UUCP. Und dann haben wir diese UUCP-Feed, die wir dann über einen Freund an der Uni bekommen haben, haben wir weitergeleitet. Da gab es dann so ein Store-and-Forward-Netz, Fido auch und so wie all diese anderen Netze. UUCP war Store and Forward von Mail und News und wir haben da einen Feed aus der Uni bekommen, einfach anrufen, ein paar Mal am Tag mit Modem und das dann weiterverbreitet an anderen Leuten. Da gab es dann zu Höhepunkten, in Ende 92 gab es da so 60 Notes, glaube ich.
50, 60 Notes.
Und da war dann schon ein Protonetz, war schon da von Leuten, die dann Mail und News über uns hatten.
Wer ist denn VIA in dem Fall?
VIA ist eine Gruppe von Techies, die sich um dieses Zeitschrift Hektik, wir sind in 89 angefangen, haben wir eine Zeitschrift daraus gegeben, www.hektik.net, da stehen alle alten Ausgaben. Und Hektik war ein bisschen wie Datenschleuder, hatte Humor, alles auf Holländisch, aber hatte Humor, hatte politische Antrieb, das muss jetzt mal frei sein oder das muss jetzt nicht sein, dass wir für Amerika 6 Gulden, also sagen wir mal 6 D-Mark die Minute zahlen. Aber da gab es diese politische Antrieb, das war auch teilweise motiviert von Sachen, die ich dann gelesen habe, als ich junger war, zum Beispiel Bluff, das war das Zeitschrift der Hausbesetzer-Bewegung in Amsterdam und die hatten auch so Technik, wie kommt man denn in ein Haus rein, um es zu besetzen, wie macht man da, dass man nicht fürs Gas zahlen muss, wie, so da gab es auch Technik in diese Szene und da gab es auch Leute, die sich damit, die da begabt waren und die das auch aufgeschrieben haben und die da auch diesen Humor hatten und dieser Hausbesetzer-Humor war auch Teil meiner Inspiration dann für Hektik. Also da gibt es auch so Faden aus der Hausbesetzer-Bewegung in unsere Bewegung rein.
Lockpicking ist sicherlich auch eine Disziplin gewesen, die dabei war, oder?
Ja, obwohl wir da das erste, glaube ich in Europa das erste Artikel geschrieben haben in Hektik, was das mal richtig ausarbeitet hat, was kann man da wirklich machen und wie funktioniert das nachher jetzt richtig?
Hektik, also Hektik kam Ende der 80er raus, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es ja auch schon die Verbindung zum CCC, oder? Ihr wart ja auch schon früh beim Kongress.
Naja, der erste Hektik war fertig, außer das eine Artikel übers Kongress, bevor wir dahin gegangen sind, im Dezember 88. Wir sind dann in Sommer 88, waren Vau, Steffen und Jürgen Wigmann in Amsterdam, in Paradiso, nach Einladung von Caroline Nevian, erzählt über Chaos.
Also Vau war Holland und Steffen, Steffen Werneri, um es mal ausgesprochen zu haben, die am Anfang erheblich auch, vor allem in der Öffentlichkeit, aber auch nach innen in den Club mit repräsentiert haben.
Ja, die haben also in Amsterdam den Club vertreten, was machen wir da, wo stehen wir, was sind wir. Die haben da eine Präsentation in Paradiso gemacht, für, naja, da waren vielleicht 100 Leute.
Paradiso ist, muss man dazu sagen, dieses große Veranstaltungszentrum.
Paradiso ist eine alte Kirche in Amsterdam, die Veranstaltungszentrum war und immer noch ist, wo sowohl Konzerte sind, als auch politische Sachen und ziemlich bekannt in ganz Holland. Also in Paradiso sind die dann hingekommen, haben das erzählt und ich hab dann spät davon gehört, erst ein paar Tage vorher und bin dann einfach, weil ich war damals schon Hacker, hab mich Hacker gefühlt, hatte schon Steven Levy gelesen.
Hacker's Heroes of the Computer Revolution.
Also ich kannte, ich wusste schon, was ich war. Dieses Moment war für mich dieses Buch, glaube ich, zu realisieren, ah, das bin ich. Ich bin doch nicht ganz alleine und komisch, da ist schon was. Und dann bin ich also nach Paradiso gegangen, hab da Carolin kennengelernt, ein paar Tage vorher und hab dann mitgeholfen an diese Organisation und Carolin erinnert sich noch diese, ja, was war ich, 20, dieser 20-jährigen Typ, der einfach reingelaufen ist und getan hat, als wäre er da zu Hause, weil war ja seine Bewegung, was wir da machen.
Was war denn das für eine Veranstaltung?
Das war eigentlich nur eine Präsentation, das war einfach Tisch, drei Leute dahinter, mal erzählen für 100 in einem kleinen Raum.
Also es ging sozusagen nur um den CCC, die sind gekommen und haben präsentiert?
Caroline hat gedacht, da passiert was Wichtiges und hat die mal eingeladen, um zu erzählen, worüber geht das denn jetzt.
Und dann hast du zugehört?
Dann habe ich zugehört, dann habe ich viel Zeit auch im Nachhinein verbracht mit diesen drei, einfach um zu hören. Mein Deutsch war zu dem Zeitpunkt echt noch schlecht. Ich hatte auf der Schule immer die schlechteste Noten für Deutsch, die es überhaupt gab. Von uns geht es von 1 bis 10, das ist ganz schlecht, das ist ganz gut. Und ich war der Einzige in der Historie, meine Schule, die auf seine Endnote im Jahr war an 1 für Deutsch, also richtig schlecht, hat nichts gemacht.
Also in Holland ist 1 das schlechteste?
Das schlechteste und 10 das beste, ja. Und ich war der Einzige, der auf seine Endnote das schlechteste überhaupt hatte. Dieses Jahr bin ich dann auch stecken geblieben. Aber mittlerweile hat sich das einigermaßen...
Hat sich gebessert, kann ich bestätigen. Auf jeden Fall. Wobei ich glaube, Schule und Hacker ist auch nicht unbedingt die optimale Paarung.
Nee, gerade so die Schulen, wo ich war, die waren echt nicht so richtig vorbereitet auf Leute, die das alles nicht so linear aus dem Buch, das ganze Jahr. Ich erinnere mich noch gut, die ersten zwei Wochen waren immer cool, dann habe ich die Bücher gelesen. Und dann hätte ich echt noch locker zwei Wochen weiter drüber reden können. Aber so ein ganzes Jahr, das war mir dann auch irgendwie zu doof. Und dass dann da die Sätze, die dann halbwegs auswendig lernen und wenn man die nicht richtig in die richtige Reihenfolge reproduziert hat, man kann, nee, das war mir dann doof.
Studiert hast du dann auch nicht?
Nee, ich habe niemals Abitur gemacht. Die sechs Klassen, die es bei uns gibt, habe ich dann die dritte zwei Mal gemacht, dann die vierte zwei Mal gemacht. Nachdem ich dann schon einmal Schule gewechselt hat, dann werfen die eins raus. Und dann war ich in der fünfte und hatte ich einfach keinen Bock mehr und bin dann gegangen. Dann hatte ich auch schon einen Job, einen Freund helfen, der hat einen Computer laden.
In der fünften Klasse?
Nein, dann ist man 17 in Holland. Bei uns gehen die Klassen noch mal von eins auf sechs ab zwölf.
Okay, also sowas wie zwölfte Klasse bei uns.
Das mag sein, ja.
Das kenne ich mich nicht.
Andere Länder, andere Dinge.
Ja, genau. Aber so mit 17, wo man normalerweise 17 ist, ich war dann schon fast 19, bin ich dann gegangen, habe ich gesagt.
Das bringt eh nichts.
Ja, mir ging es auf der Uni ähnlich.
Ja, und dann habe ich ein paar Monate gearbeitet für einen Freund, der hatte dann so ein Computer-Verkaufsding mit PCs und Boxen hin und her schieben. Und da habe ich ein bisschen geschrieben und Sachen getan.
Was kam denn jetzt bei diesem Zusammentreffen mit den drei Jungs vom Club? Was kam denn da für dich bei Ruba? Also was war denn da so die Botschaft?
Ich war immer schon an dieser Kreuzung zwischen Technik und politischen Sachen interessiert. Das war mein Ding. So war es. Wo geht die Welt hin? Schon richtig jung, schon mit 14 war ich da richtig interessiert. Wo geht das jetzt hin? Wo geht das lang? Und das war halt mein Ding und die waren alle ziemlich politisch auch bewusst und aktiv. Und ich kannte eigentlich nur Techies, die mit politischen Sachen überhaupt nichts hatten und die zwar richtig sich mit Modem und Computer auskennt, aber nicht mit der Politik. Und da bin ich lange, lange, lange in Holland auch eigentlich der Einzige gewesen. Obwohl das in Hektik nicht so schien, auch weil ich da unter neuen Namen geschrieben habe.
Unter welchem denn?
Na ja, so fast alle aus Hektik war eigentlich ich. Gerade so die ersten 5, 6 Ausgaben war echt voll die Simulation. Ich weiß noch gut, dass wir für das erste Mal angefangen haben, Leserbriefe zu bekommen und dann hatten wir schon echt ein Jahr lang ein Leserbrief in der Rubrik. Die erste Leserbrief kam aber ein Jahr nachdem wir diesen Rubrik hatten, wo auch schon Briefe drin waren.
Ja, so kann man auch Nachfrage erzeugen.
Gerade die ersten zwei Jahren waren voll der Simulation. Erst später habe ich dann gehört, dass die beim Staat, beim BWD, unser Verfassungsschutz, da richtig voll drauf eingegangen sind. Niemals geschnallt haben, dass das eigentlich zwei, drei Typen waren.
Sondern die dachten, das wäre einfach eine richtige Organisation.
Und steht eine Organisation, eine neue Massenbewegung gegenüber. Die sind da mit 30, 40 Leuten und machen allerhand Sachen und das war überhaupt nicht der Fall. Gerade so die ersten zwei, drei Jahre war das überhaupt nicht der Fall.
Wartet ihr denn da schon von vornherein gleich der Feind?
Kann ich nicht so sagen, ob wir der Feind waren, aber wir waren auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Nachrichtendienste gehen von zwei Sachen aus. Was können die und was wollen die? Capabilities and Intention und naja, was wollen, naja, das hat so Links mit Hausbesetzerbewegungen und die sind alles so ein bisschen radikal und wollen Sachen mit, die Banken machen Sachen falsch und Telekom ist nicht gut und naja, da war schon etwas Politisches und können, naja, können auf jeden Fall mehr als wir das mit Computer verstehen, wenn nicht so ganz und alles, was überall, wo wir reden, so mit unsere großen Unternehmen, die auch mit Computersachen tun, da gibt es alles jetzt großer Panik, weil die haben auch Modems und Computer und verstehen das alles nicht. Man muss verstehen, dass dies war eine Zeit, dass man Unternehmen einfach mal die 1000 Telefonnummer durchgescannt hat, vom Hand noch, Modemnummer gefunden hat, da waren Fax VMS, System System, und man war drin und man hatte da alles, was da auf dem Rechner war.
Standard Password.
Standard Password, das war diese Zeit.
Hacking leicht gemacht.
Ja.
Und das wurde dann natürlich auch gemacht und man hat mal geguckt.
Ja, und das würde auch von den Unternehmen und von den Nachrichtendiensten wahrgenommen. Da gibt es jetzt keine, da gibt es für uns noch keine Verteidigung. Wenn die mal was Schlimmes wollen, und ich glaube nicht, dass wir mal eingeschätzt worden sind, dass wir wollen richtig, richtig schlimme Sachen, sondern die wollen immer mal was und auf jeden Fall haben wir keine Verteidigung.
Capabilities sind sozusagen groß, aber die Intentions sind unklar.
Die Intentions sind unklar und wahrscheinlich nicht so schlecht, aber die sind unklar, aber die Capabilities sind groß und auf jeden Fall für uns nicht richtig einzuschätzen. Und das war für die schon, glaube ich, also im Nachhinein habe ich schon mit ein paar Leute geredet und das war für die nicht immer lustig.
Also HACKtick war im Prinzip eine kleine Community, in der du viel gemacht hast, aber auch nicht alleine warst und die das Magazin erzeugt hat und die aber auch sozusagen Usenit geschaufelt hat. Also HACKtick Networks hast du für ihn gesagt, also ihr habt sozusagen einfach teilgenommen an der Datenverteilung.
Ja, HACKtick hatte eigentlich drei Teile. Es gab das Zeitschrift, es gab unsere eigene Technischen Research Department und da haben wir auch Sachen verkauft, einfach auch um ein bisschen Geld zu haben. Da gab es Demon Dialers, Geräte, womit man umsonst telefonieren konnte und auch ein bisschen das Telefonnetz da rumlaufen konnte und Sachen tun. Das hat so funktioniert, dass man Nummern anrufen konnten, die dann größteils im Ausland waren, aber die in Holland als umsonst Nummer anwählbar waren. Und wo man dann mit einem Trick das Telefonnetz in einen komischen Zustand gebracht hat, nämlich der Zustand, wobei der Remote-Vermittlungsstelle, zum Beispiel in Frankreich oder in Dänemark oder wo auch immer, gedacht hat, das Gespräch wäre jetzt vorbei. Und die lokale Vermittlungsstelle bei uns, beim Post, bei KPN hat immer noch gedacht, dass das Gespräch ist noch ongoing. Und diese Zustand erzeugte man meistens dadurch, dass man diese Quittungston, die Ton, die normalerweise auf dieser Leitung ist, um anzugeben, dass jetzt nicht benutzt, diese Leitung ist jetzt frei, dieser Ton hat man gesendet und dann kommt von der andere Seite die gleiche Ton zurück. Und dann geht es auch das Gespräch auch hier weg. Und man hat die Ton so lange gesendet, dass er nicht mehr zurückkommen konnte, dass das Gespräch beendet war, aber dass der Zurückton nicht lange genug gesendet wurde. Und dann gab es diesen Zustand, wobei der Remote-Vermittlungsstelle dachte, ah, es fängt ein neues Gespräch an, weil der Ton ist wieder weg. Und dann haben wir mit diesen Tönen, da gab es mehrere Arten von, konnte man dann signalisieren, wo das Gespräch hin sollte. Und weil der lokale Vermittlungsstelle das letzte war, wo die Rechnung gemacht wurde, gab es dann keine Rechnung. Da konnte man auch weiter wählen. Man konnte Transit über mehrere Länder, Transit von uns ein ins andere, ins andere. Da konnte man immer weiter Transit machen. Man könnte also vom einen Telefon über Asien, Australien, Amerika wieder zurück aufs andere Telefon, was da gleich daneben stand. Und dann hat man Hallo gesagt und dann kam so zwei Sekunden später Hallo, kam zurück.
Datenreisen.
Datenreisen, das war richtig, das hat Spaß gemacht.
Und das Telefonnetzwerk war ja eigentlich das erste wirkliche internationale Netzwerk, was man sich ja so, was ja eigentlich dem Internet sozusagen noch vorausging. Und dieses Phonefreaking, also Hacking von Telefonnetzen, war ja auch sozusagen in den 70er, 80er Jahren eigentlich so der primäre Hacksport. Das war ja auch stark in den USA vorher.
Ja, obwohl es in Europa spät gekommen ist. Es ist in Europa erst ab 91 oder so, würde hier Phonefreaking gemacht. Lange Zeit war da so ein Ding, wo ich mal gelesen hatte in diese Bücher, aber dass es hier wirklich gemacht wurde, da war wichtig, dass Bill Squire aus Amerika nach Amsterdam kam und eine Weile bei uns gelebt hat. Und er hat eine Menge Wissen aus Kalifornien mitgebracht, was es da so alles an Telefonen-Sachen gibt.
Na ja, klar, mangels Internetverbreitung muss man erst mal die Personen exportieren, um überhaupt dieses kulturelle Wissen da auch weiter zu tragen. Aber das ist auch interessant, dass du das sagst. Ich hatte nämlich auch damals so das Gefühl, dass Amsterdam auch so ein bisschen so das verbindungs-, also auch das personelle Verbindungsglied dann war zu den USA. Also quasi so ein Einfallstor jetzt nicht nur für Daten, sondern auch so ein Einfallstor für so die internationale Hacker-Community. Man, Amsterdam hat ja auch in den USA einfach einen besonderen Ruf und gilt als ein besonderes attraktives Reiseziel, das Mark dazu beigetragen haben. Da lag Berlin wahrscheinlich noch nicht ganz so weit vorne, was natürlich auch damit zu tun hat, dass eben auch Amsterdam sich als eine sehr internationale Stadt verstanden hat, wo die Leute immer schon viel Englisch gesprochen haben. Alte Reisenationen.
Ich denke, dass das Amsterdam hat so die Rolle in der Hacker-Community, so die Rolle gespielt, die Verbindung zwischen Amerika und Deutschland zu sein. In beiden Ländern war, glaube ich, realbetrachtet mehr los als in Amsterdam. Aber wir haben halt sowohl Deutsch als Englisch gesprochen. Und es gab zu dem Zeitpunkt, zu Ende der 80er, war ich auf einem Kongress in Hamburg. Da waren vielleicht 250 Menschen. Und da hat echt die wenigsten haben Englisch gesprochen. Da gab es vielleicht 10, 15 Leute, die vernünftig Englisch gesprochen haben. Du warst einer. Und da gab es vielleicht noch 10. Aber die anderen 200 hat man dann doch echt in so ein Mix von Englisch und Deutsch. Und dass da Speicher auch Memory war, ja, war so halt noch unklar.
Das stimmt. Das hat sich erst langsam durchgesetzt.
Das hat sich langsam durchgesetzt. Genau. Und das war das, also das Großteil der deutschen Szene konnte echt nicht mit Amerikanern vernünftig kommunizieren. Da haben wir echt noch eine Brückenrolle gespielt.
Ja, das denke ich auch, also auch in jeder Hinsicht, also auch was so die kulturelle Vermittlung betrifft. Ich meine, unabhängig von der Sprache, denke ich mal, es fiel es den Holländern auch schon immer leichter, mit den Amerikanern klarzukommen. Das mag jetzt so ein bisschen meine persönliche Sicht sein, aber so hat sich mir das dargestellt. Also gerade die Amerikaner, die ich jetzt auch damals immer in Amsterdam getroffen habe, die waren da einfach auf eine Art und Weise eingebettet, wie ich mir das so in Deutschland zu dem Zeitpunkt so hätte nicht vorstellen können. Was auch eben mit der Sprache zu tun hat, also mit der Sprache fängt es irgendwie an, aber auch irgendwie der sonstige kulturelle Kontext war einfach, Deutschland war dann auch zu schwierig zu verstehen und wahrscheinlich auch einfach zu groß und zu sehr in sich selbst vergessen, während Holland als kleines Land schon immer irgendwie auf den Kontakt mit anderen Ländern angewiesen war.
Ja, Holländer sind ein Händlervolk. Wir waren immer schon dabei, um irgendwo die Sprache zu lernen, zu verstehen, was treibt hier die Leute und wie verdienen wir da Geld dran?
Ja, so grob gesagt.
Ja, stimmt. Die Deutschen haben dann die Maschinen gebaut. Ja, die Demon-Dialers, ach ja, das waren ja begehrte Objekte, muss ich sagen. Also waren ja immer alle ganz stolz, die so einen hatten. So, hier, ich habe einen original Hektik-Demon-Dialer. Das heißt, so diese Trinität, Zeitungen, digitale Aktivitäten und dann eben auch so der Gerätebau, das hat sozusagen da die Kultur ausgemacht. Und das lief so ein paar Jahre. Aber irgendwann war es noch gut.
Aber es waren wenig Menschen. Diese ganze drei Dinge haben wir getrieben mit einer Gruppe von vielleicht zehn Leuten, weniger noch. Das war in Amsterdam nie so eine richtige Szene von Hunderten von Menschen. Es waren vielleicht zehn Leute. Und dann waren auch die Leute, die dann zur Party gekommen sind oder einfach da waren für die Atmosphäre, die aber nicht entweder total Ahnung von Politik oder Computer hatten, sondern die das einfach gesehen haben, hier ist was los. Aber gewachsen ist das erst später.
Wie ging es denn dann weiter? Also ich meine, die Zeitung ist ja nicht ewig gelaufen. Datenschleuder gibt es heute noch. Aber irgendwann war dein Hektik auch so vorbei für euch.
Naja, ich bin sowieso nicht so jemand, der 20, 30 Jahre das Gleiche machen kann. Ich kann nicht... Eric Corley macht das, Emmanuel Goldstein, der macht das in Amerika immer noch, 2600. Der hat in 1984 angefangen. Ich bewundere das, weil der macht wichtige Sachen. Da laufen Sachen. Aber ich könnte das selber nicht so...
Der ist extrem beständig. Jede Woche Radio.
Ja, also für mich, nach vier Jahren Hektik, eigentlich nur, es hat es nur vier Jahre gegeben, hat sich für mich angefangen, die Sache zu repetieren. Wieder neue Tricks, um sonst zu telefonieren, wieder neue. Und irgendwann sieht man diese Repetition und dann denkt man, ich muss mal was Neues machen.
Und was war das dann?
Na ja, Hektik-Netwerk ist dann in 92 angefangen mit diesen UUCP und Newsfeeds. Und da wollten wir dann das echte Internet haben, IP. Und da gab es auch die Möglichkeit, weil diese ganze Sache in Amsterdam war. Und ein Least Line, also eine Telefonleitung, die man quasi nicht auflegen muss, war nicht so teuer. Least Lines innerhalb Amsterdam waren eigentlich noch bezahlbar. Da musste man zwei Modems dranhängen, aber dann hätte man Datenkontakt zu wissenschaftlichem Zentrum in Amsterdam, wo dann diese Rechner standen. Und dann hatte man IP. Das hat dann so, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was es gekostet hat, aber so 1000, 2000 Gulden im Monat. Das war teuer. Das war, sagen wir mal, 1000 Mark, 500 Euro im Monat. Das war für uns echt unendlich viel Geld. Aber es war auch nicht, dass wir das nicht untereinander mit einer Gruppe teilen konnten. Das war nicht komplett unbezahlbar. Dann haben wir einen Rechner aufgestellt. Der Rechner hieß Xs4All. Die Organisation war derzeit echt noch Hektik-Nettwerk. Das Domain war auch hektik.ne. Aber der Rechner hieß Xs4All. Und da so, Xs4All.hektik.ne war der Rechner, wo man dann einen Account bekommen konnte für 30 Gulden im Monat. Und dann konnte man mit ins Netz. Da konnte man alles noch mit Text, man konnte aber Telnet tippen, man konnte SSH tippen und man konnte mit Gopher, der Vorläufer vom World Wide Web, konnte man auch Daten reisen. Man konnte von der einen Gopher-Server auf der anderen. Das ist quasi World Wide Web mit Menüs. Also nicht mit Hyperlinks in den Text, sondern du hattest Menüs und diese Menüs haben entweder auf neue Menüs oder auf Texte gezeigt. So muss man das sich eigentlich vorstellen. Und so konnte man dann so ein bisschen Daten reisen. Und das haben wir dann in Mai 1993, haben wir das online gemacht, Anfang Mai, und gedacht, jetzt brauchen wir aber ein paar hundert Leute, um das alles bezahlen zu können. Die Modems, die Telefonleitungen, die da einkommend gehen, die Kosten für das Netz, für die Internetanbindung, Computer, alles. Wir haben gesagt, wir brauchen 500 Leute, und wir geben uns selber ein halbes Jahr, um die zu bekommen. Weil ansonsten können wir das nicht leisten, und dann machen wir es wieder zu. So war so ein bisschen der Gedanke.
Das heißt, ihr hattet sozusagen die Leitung schon, und dann habt ihr euch gesagt, so jetzt brauchen wir aber auch Leute, die das benutzen.
Nee, nee, wir haben die Leitung genommen mit dieser Gedanke. Wir müssen das mit Leuten teilen. Aber wir hatten da schon so eine Art von Plan. Wir machen vier Modems dran, damit sich Leute vernünftig einwählen können. Also das Plan war schon da und das Geld kam damals von Philipp, Philipp Rodriguez, einer, der mit eingebunden war in Hectic Network zu dem Zeitpunkt. Er hatte auch die größte andere Note. Die Hauptnote war bei mir zu Hause, aber Utopia, dort Hectic, dort Enel, war seine Note. Und bei ihm hingen dann eigentlich die ganzen UECP Notes drunter, fast alle. Das lief bei ihm zu Hause. So Utopia und meine Note waren die zwei großen Notes im Netz. Und Philipp war, seine Eltern waren gestorben und er war Besitzer eines spanischen Restaurants in Amsterdam. Und der hatte schon einige Ahnung, obwohl er 18 war, der war ein Jahr junger als ich. Nee, der war zu dem Zeitpunkt schon älter. Aber obwohl er jung war, der hatte mit 18 in ein Restaurant bekommen, obwohl er jung war, der war 20, hatte der schon einige Ahnung von A. Geld, B. Management, wie macht man einen Plan? Da hatten wir alle überhaupt keine Ahnung. Überhaupt keinen Plan, keine Ahnung. Und er hatte schon ein bisschen Ahnung und wir haben dann zusammen uns gesessen und haben einen Plan gemacht. Und so ging das dann los am 1. Mai 93. Da waren aber ein paar Journalisten, die zu dem Zeitpunkt geschnallt hatten, da ist was Großes. Im Wesentlichen zwei Journalisten. Einer davon hatte auf diesem Tag ein seitengroßes Artikel in einer der größten Zeitungen in Holland, was jetzt da passiert und dass das cool ist. Und wir hatten da so gehofft, wir haben 500 Abonnenten im ersten halben Jahr. Und die Nummer 500 haben wir dann gecloggt am nächsten Tag. Um sieben Uhr abends.
Wie, jetzt 500 Kunden innerhalb eines Tages?
Eines Tages. Dann haben wir uns realisiert, wir haben mit Kundenzufluss ein Problem. Es ist aber nicht das Problem, was wir befürchtet haben. Es ist das andere Problem.
Too many customer error. Wie konnte sich dann das so schnell rumsprechen? Also meine 500 Leute 1993, die wirklich Internetzugang haben wollen, das ist ja eine riesige Zahl jetzt überhaupt erst mal so viele.
Du musst nicht vergessen, alle Studenten in Holland hatten schon Internet. Alle zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Aber sie konnten sich an der Uni nicht einwählen, weil die Uni selber keine Einwahlports bereitgestellt hat.
Gerade die technischen Studien hatten schon fünf Jahre Internet, sechs Jahre, sieben Jahre Internet teilweise. Die hatten schon seit den 80ern Usenet, Mail, das waren die alle schon gewohnt. Es gab also auch schon eine Menge Ex-Studenten, die wieder zurück aufs Internet wollten. Es gab schon eine ganze Generation Studenten, die mal die ganze Welt gesehen hatten und dann plötzlich so abgedreht wurden. Und dann gab es die ganze, du hast es schon erwähnt, Amsterdam ist eine internationale Stadt, gerade so in den in den atlantischen englischsprachigen Welt. Da gab es also auch echt viele Amerikaner und Engländer, die das von zu Hause schon gekannt haben. Die man in England war zwei Jahre vor uns und gerade in Amerika lief diese ganze Revolution schon zwei, drei Jahren. Da gab es also eine Menge Amerikaner, die das einfach für sich brauchten, die das, die da einfach gesucht haben, wo will ich mir jetzt ein? Ich bin jetzt in Amsterdam, wo will ich mir ein? Und da gab es nichts. Also schon diese Communities haben schon, waren schon Anfang Kundschaft.
So wie es einem heute so geht, wenn man irgendwo hinkommt und es gibt irgendwie kein WLAN oder kein Netz, schlimm. Okay, 500 an einem Tag. Und was habt ihr dann gemacht?
Also im Grunde die logische Reaktion, blinder Panik. Und dann haben wir uns überlegt, wir brauchen schnell neue Modems. Das hat dann aber noch eine Weile gedauert, weil wir mittlerweile auch dabei waren, das erste Hacker-Camp zu organisieren. Wie das da in 93 alles reingepasst hat, weiß ich bis zu heute nicht. Aber zu dem gleichen Punkt, dass wir auch diese ganze Xs4All aufgemacht haben, haben wir auch dieses erste Camp organisiert. Das hat in 89, so einem Jahr nach, dass Steffen und Jürgen in Amsterdam waren, haben wir schon die Galactic Hacker Party gemacht und da hatten wir dann sowohl Deutsche als auch die Amerikaner eingeladen. Das war so das Kontakt treffen zwischen Amerikaner wie Lee Fesenstein, der in Berkley Community Memory gemacht hat und die ganzen Deutschen, die da in dem Bereich aktiv waren. Das war dann schon in 89.
Auch der Erfinder und Designer des Osborn-1 Computers.
Ja, der Ausdenker von Memory-Mapped Displays. Der hat schon eine Menge Pionierarbeit geleistet, auch im Personal Computer Design. Aber das war schon in 89, aber in 93, vier Jahre später, wollten wir dann was ganz anderes machen. Da habe ich mir überlegt, eigentlich müssen wir mal nach draußen, weil dieses Image von Hacker ist immer, die sitzen da im dunklen Keller und wollen nicht nach draußen, sind ungesund, zu dick, dicke Brille, weiß ich was. Und dann waren in die Medien in 93 Images von junge Leute mit Kabel zwischen die Zähne geklemmt, die in Bäume geklettert sind.
Also Hacking at the End of the Universe ist im Prinzip das erste Hacker-Open-Air-Camp gewesen.
Überhaupt in die Welt, ja.
Überhaupt auf der ganzen Welt, auch noch weit vor dem Chaos Communication Camp, wer nur das kennt. Und fand statt, wo war das nochmal genau? Also auf dem Campingplatz?
So ein Gruppencampingplatz, die man als Ganzes mieten konnte in Lelystad. Camping Larger Bosch in Lelystad. So mitten in der Mitte von nichts, Stadt war ein paar Kilometer weg, so ein Stückchen mit Bäumen.
Das war wirklich unglaublich. Da war ich ja dann auch auf der Veranstaltung. Das war glaube ich dann die erste holländische Veranstaltung, die ich so mitbekommen habe. War ja eigentlich auch erst die zweite. Irre. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Heutzutage ist man ja gewohnt, dass man überall irgendwie Internet bekommt. Aber damals war einfach der Gedanke, dass man da überhaupt Internet haben könnte. Das war schon so utopisch. Aber es gab ja dann doch zwei...
Also UTP war noch nicht in Benutzung. Es war alles noch coax. Das kennen Leute heute nicht mehr, aber es gab so 50 Ohm Coaxialkabel mit BNC-Konnektoren.
Was man sonst nur für Fernsehantennen verwendet.
Und dann hat man an beiden Seiten noch einen Terminator-Widerstand gehabt, damit das nicht irgendwie die falsche Impedanz hatte. Und da gab es dann so üble Spannungsunterschiede, weil die Computer auch nie ganz gut gegroundet waren. Wenn man das mal weggemacht hat, war dann so mal 100 Volt Spannungsdifferential da drauf. Das waren schon üble Netze. Und wenn irgendwo ein Kabel ab war, dann gingen nicht nur diese Computer nicht, sondern dann ging das ganze Netz nicht mehr.
Ja, das war ja ein Bus. Das war ja sozusagen nicht ein Kabel zu einem Switch oder so. So was gab es nicht. Sondern eigentlich war sozusagen Zelt an Zelt. Es gab so ein Kabel sozusagen von Zelt zu Zelt. Und überall versuchte sich jeder anzuschließen. Und am Ende waren, glaube ich, zwei US-Robotics Modems dran. Zyxl Modems?
19K2.
Das war ja schon irre schnell.
19.000 Bits pro Sekunde, ja.
Das war ja schon die Zukunft. Ich weiß nicht, wie oft gab es tatsächlich, kam wirklich deine Internetverbindung zustande, irgendwo hin?
Naja, das größte Teil der Zeit hatten wir, im Nock zumindest, hatten wir Netz. Da draußen war es mal kaputt wegen Wasser in der Coax-Kabel. Aber auch hat es ziemlich oft Netz gegeben. Man konnte von seinem Zettel aus Telneten und Gofer machen, in 390 im Zettel. Das ging. Eine Leitung war für Mail und News, einer dieser 19.2 Leitungen, und einer war für Live IP. Damals mit Slip.
Wow, das war irgendwie ein irres Erlebnis, zu diesem frühen Zeitpunkt schon eine Technologie auf den Acker zu tragen, die eigentlich die meisten Leute noch nicht mal zu Hause hatten, geschweige denn ihren Unternehmen.
Ja, das war auch die paar Leute, die dann als Unternehmen da waren, die die schlüpsten, die dann da waren, das war echt, die waren da so voll erstaunt, wie lange haben wir denn gebraucht, dieses Netz bei uns da irgendwie am Laufen zu bekommen? Und die machen das hier in drei Tage? Und wie viele gerechnet? Hunderte? Das war für die echt schon hart.
Das war irre. Das hat auch eine Menge bewegt. Das war so mein Eindruck.
Was mir am wichtigsten war, ist dieses Public Image war danach echt anders. Dass da junge Leute mit Kabel zwischen den Zähnen im Bäume, das war im Evening News.
Davon habe ich ja wenig mitbekommen. Wie war denn so die mediale Wahrnehmung in Holland?
Wir sind immer groß in den Medien gewesen.
Warum?
Weil es dann doch Journalisten geschneuert haben, dass da was Wichtiges war. Es waren immer wenige Journalisten, aber die haben das dann doch immer vertreten bekommen, dass da was Großes läuft.
Hat das schon mit Hectic angefangen?
Ja, das war schon seit Ende der 80er, war das schon so. Weil wir hatten da auch große komische Geschichten, oder große interessante oder amusante Geschichten, dass wir umsonst anrufen konnten. Und dann kam natürlich der Telekom und haben gesagt, nee, das ist alles unmöglich und unser Netz ist gut abgesichert. Und damals gab es auch diese erste Sex-Lines und so, wo man dann extra Geld bezahlt hat. Diese Sondertarif-Leitungen. Und dann gab es auch diese erste Frauds, wobei Leute dann irgendwo Access zu Telefonleitungen bekommen hatten. Zum Beispiel in Hochhäusern, da waren die Leitungen einfach durch den gleichen Schacht. Da konnte jeder sich an jeder Leitung klemmen. Und da gab es also großen Fraud mit diesen Sondertarif-Leitungen. Da gab es dann immer diese Telekom, die gesagt hatten, das geht alles nicht und unsere Infrastruktur ist schon sicher. Und jedes Mal haben wir dann gezeigt, na ja, sicher, sicher, hier guck mal, hier ist unser Hochhaus, hier guck mal, diese Leitung kann ich jetzt schlitzmal einmal aufschneiden und dann Telefon rauf, guck mal, jetzt ist es eine andere Leitung. Also so einfach ist das.
Also im Prinzip habt ihr damals auch schon so eine ähnliche Rolle übernommen wie der CCC auch in Deutschland.
Ja.
Dass man viel mit den Medien kommuniziert hat.
Schon vom Anfang an, ja. Und wir haben noch die gleiche Strategie gefahren, die mir eigentlich von Vau eingeprägt worden ist, Vau Holland, nämlich das Benutzen der Sexiness von dieser Schwachstellen in Rechner und dieser Sexiness von das Computer Security-Thema, um auch die anderen politischen Themen irgendwie mit reinzuschleichen. Das hat Vau, als ich ihn kennengelernt habe, in 88 schon voll verstanden. Wir können dieses sexy Thema einfach ausnutzen, um unsere ganzen anderen politischen Themen in die Presse zu kriegen. Weil die Presse wird niemals genug haben von Hackerraum Bank aus oder Hacker. Wir haben da unendliche Zugang zur Presse. Und das hat er schon klar gesehen, dass man das ausnutzen soll, um die Welt besser zu machen. Weil unendliche Zugang zur Presse bringt Macht. Und die Macht kann man ausnutzen. Und das haben wir in Holland auch genauso gemacht. Es gibt auch andere Themen und das war dann so ein Beisatz in das ganze Artikel, was sich natürlich darüber gehandelt hat, dass das Netz nicht sicher ist oder dass der Telekom wieder gesagt hat, ist sicher oder der Bank hat gesagt, ist sicher.
Aber trotzdem war immer noch so ein bisschen so ein negatives Image auch immer noch mit dabei.
Ja, obwohl das lange gedauert hat, bevor das dann so dominant wurde, als es jetzt ist. Das positive Image von Hacker hat in Holland echt lange standegehalten, weil wir ja die Hacker ja immer mit quasi positive Sachen in der Presse waren. Es war alle klar, dass man uns vertrauen konnte. Wenn wir sagen, es ist so und entweder Bank oder Großunternehmen oder Telekom hat gesagt, nein, ist anders, dann hatten wir immer recht. Uns konnte man vertrauen, die anderen alle nicht.
Dieser Robin Hood-Faktor ist das.
Ja, aber auch weil wir da einfach keine großen Interessen dran hatten, irgendwie Lügen zu verbreiten. Und jeder sehen konnte ja natürlich, will der Telekom gerne, dass man glaubt, dass das alles sicher ist. Und natürlich würden die Banken gerne, dass man glaubt, dass das alles... Und diese Hacker haben da, die wollen da ja nur erzählen, was da die Risiken sind und was da die... Und das war auch immer so, wie gerade hier in Deutschland auch der CCC. Es hat halt alles Vorteile. Man kann da richtig gute Sachen machen, aber es hat auch Nachteile. Und es hat auch Risiken und da muss man sich offen drüber unterhalten können. Und das muss nicht nur die Unternehmen machen, die damit gerade zufällig Geld verdienen, sondern da brauchen wir unabhängige Leute, die das erzählen können. Und diese Rolle hatten wir in Holland genauso wie der CCC, die in Deutschland hat.
Und was hat dann Hacking at the End of the Universe, das Camp, das erste, was hat das dann verändert?
Da kamen Leute hin, die nicht nur mit Colonel Hacking, da kamen auch Leute hin, die die politische Sachen interessant fanden. Das war so die erste Begegnung mit Leute, die einfach im politischen Spektrum aktiv waren, vielleicht Ahnung von Computern hatten, aber die einfach die politischen Möglichkeiten sahen. Da waren Marlene Sticker, Marianne van de Borme, die später mit uns zusammen Digitale Stadt gegründet haben. Digitale Stadt war ein Versuch, die Öffentlichkeit von Amsterdam und alle öffentlichen Informationen umsonst im Netz zugänglich zu machen, dadurch, dass man sich einwählen konnte und diese ganze Information dann hatte.
So der erste Ansatz für Bürgerinformation.
Der erste Ansatz für Bürgerinformation. Das war dann Anfang 94, ist das angefangen. Wie das alles in 93 gepasst hat, wiederum, ich weiß es alles nicht, weil wir sind in dem Zeit auch umgezogen, in so einem großen alten Haus im Zentrum von Amsterdam. Die ganzen Modems dahin umgezogen. Ja, das war alles so eine wirre, wilde Zeit. Da gibt es auch noch eine schöne Geschichte. Wir sind dann in diesem Gebäude gezogen und direkt uns gegenüber war der Nachrichtendienst, deren technischen Auswertungszentrum für Signals Intelligence und gerade so die Marineinformation. Was ist dann von Empfangstationen der Küste entlang an Signalen, so alles kam. Damals gab es noch russische U-Boote und alles, diese ganze kalte Krieg war noch nicht vorbei so ganz. Und dass wir dann in diese Gebäude gezogen sind.
Also wir, Xs4All dann zu dem Punkt.
Ja, Xs4All und Hektik und auch wir, da war noch eine WG daneben.
Also es war sozusagen noch alles eins.
War noch alles eins. Wir sind in diesem Gebäude gezogen, auch mit digitaler Stadt alles. Und dann haben wir immer wieder Telefonleitungen bestellt. Weil es war zu dem Zeitpunkt echt noch besonders, wenn man 20 Telefonleitungen bestellte. Das waren nicht so viele in der Stadt, die 20 Leitungen hatten. Und es waren auch nicht so viele, die dann drei Monate später noch mal 20 geordert haben und noch mal 40 und 80 und 120 und so. Diese Hochstafflung von Telefonleitungen, das kannte man noch nicht. Da gab es so Telefon-Engineers, die dann kamen.
Aber ihr wart doch nicht der erste Internet-Provider in Holland, oder doch?
Wir waren die erste Internet-Provider in Mainland Europe.
Aber es gab doch auch noch so andere, so Surfnet oder so?
Surfnet ist unser DFN. Das ist das Universitätsnetz. Das gab es schon vorher, das hat aber keine Privatpersonen angebunden.
Ihr wart sozusagen die Ersten, die jetzt tatsächlich Privatleuten zugabten?
Die ersten öffentlichen Internet-Provider auf Mainland Europe. Nur in England gab es vor uns... Es waren schon ein paar kleine Initiativen in Holland, die ungefähr gleichzeitig waren. Aber in den Rest von Mainland Europe gab es keine Möglichkeit, sich publik einzuwählen.
Aber es ging dann sozusagen sofort los. Und dann hattet ihr nach einem Jahr, wie groß war das dann?
Das habe ich nicht genau im Kopf. Aber so Sommer 1994 sind es schon 60, 70 Leitungen gewesen, glaube ich. Das würde dann immer größer. Aber da waren dann auch neue Leitungen angeschlossen. Und deswegen komme ich zu diesem Story. Bei uns gegenüber saßen dann die Nachrichtendienste. Und dann sind uns mal neue hunderte angeschnitten worden, hunderte Kabel, und zwar der falsche. Das war deren Leitung. Da kam der Siggi in treiben. Und dann war also...
Also dann hattet ihr jetzt deren Telefonnummern?
Naja, wir hatten so ein Panel gemountet. Und da waren allerhand Sachen drauf. Aber da waren für uns noch keine Leitungen angeschlossen worden. Also ich habe da... Du musst dir vorstellen, dieses Gebäude war diesmal, war zu dem Zeitpunkt noch im Umbau. Und ich war langjährigen Hippie. Und ich habe da auf einer Matratze neben dem Rechner geschlafen, weil noch kein Schlüssel auf die Türen war. Er schläft einen Hacker in einem weiter leeren Gebäude mit zwei Rechse an Equipment auf einer Matratze daneben. Alles ist kalt und es ist Winter. Der schläft daneben in einem Schlafsack mit so einer Gasheizung noch daneben, weil es war echt tierisch kalt. Und man ist Nachrichtendienst und von einer auf den anderen Tag funktionieren alle deine Seegindleitungen nicht mehr. Es ist alles weg und man ruft natürlich direkt bei der Telekom an, was ist los, was ist los? Und der Telekom sagt, ja na ja, es gab einen Fehler. Ja, was war denn der Fehler? War es schon relevant? Na, es ist unser Seegindfeed, wir sind jetzt blind, ach, grummel, fixen, fixen. Aber was war jetzt der Fehler? Na ja, ihre Leitungen sind jetzt bei Hactic Netzwerk abmontiert. Aber das fixen wir schon. Und dann ist der Typ vom Telekom an seine Kleidung überm Tisch rübergezogen und ihm ist ins Gesicht geschrien worden, das ist kein Fehler, die wollen nur, dass du glaubst, dass es ein Fehler ist. Und dann ist also, wir haben da nur bemerkt, dass da nachts Leute in so die Straße aufgebuddelt haben und da Sachen gefixt haben. Und dann haben wir gesagt, ihr arbeitet jetzt nachts? Die haben ja echt gearbeitet, ihr Leben davon abhängt. Und wahrscheinlich war das auch so.
Sie sind aber nicht bei euch aufgeschlagen?
Diese Geschichte habe ich erst Jahre später von der anderen Seite erfahren. Wir haben da nichts anderes mitbekommen, dass da Leute nachts richtig schnell was fixen mussten.
Das heißt, ihr habt diese Leitungen, die euch dazu geschlagen wurden, auch so gar nicht in Betrieb genommen?
Nein, nein, nichts. Zwei Tage später gab es dann unsere Telefonleitung. Alles war gut. Das war nur die Vorbereitungsphase für neue Leitungen. Und da ist was schiefgegangen. Aber wir waren dann so close dran. Zu dem Zeitpunkt waren einige von uns auch sehr interessiert an Polizei hinterherlaufen und gucken, was machen die geheimen Polizeileute? Und da kamen da auch noch Leute, hey, es stehen hier Zivilbullen um die Ecken, sind hier zwei, drei Autos, die ich nicht kenne, und da sitzen Leute drin. Da war so voll die Intelligence um mich herum. Und dann haben das alles nur, naja, dann gibt es hier wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Kriminellen oder Drogen. Wir haben das überhaupt nicht auf uns projiziert. Und wir waren angeblich sehr nah dran, das Gebäude geräumt zu bekommen unter Staatssicherheitsgesetze. Dass man also zwei Wochen im Knast ohne Anwalt, so richtig. Wir waren kurz davor, einfach alle eingesperrt, alles geräumt. Und das hätte Xs4All nicht überlebt. Und das nur, weil die Telekom die falschen Leitungen gefilmt hat. Aber auch gerade die richtige falsche Leitung da mal aufgeschnitten hat.
Okay, aber ihr habt Glück gehabt und Xs4All. Rapsan ist dann schnell gewachsen, war ja dann auch sehr erfolgreich. Gibt es ja auch heute noch, wenn auch mit anderen Besitzern. Das ist ja dann irgendwann von KPN, glaube ich, übernommen worden.
Genau, Ende 98.
Und da war dann sozusagen das Kapitel dann für dich auch abgeschlossen?
Ja, schon ein halbes Jahr vorher war ich da selber nicht mehr tätig. Ich habe nicht so die Talente, die man braucht, um ein Unternehmen erfolgreich groß zu machen. Oder sobald sich Leute bei mir ins Büro mal über ihre Rente-Regelung reden wollen, dann bin ich nicht der Mann, das muss ich nicht tun. Und auch mein Talent, wenn ich es mal überlege, ist es eher, Sachen kaputt zu machen. Sachen mal ein bisschen was anderes passieren zu lassen, als Sachen bestehen zu lassen oder Sachen wachsen zu lassen. Mein Talent ist es eher, die Sachen, die kaputt müssen, kaputt zu machen und was Neues dafür auszudenken, als dann das weiterzutreiben. Ja, oder der politischen Urge, Veränderungen zu schaffen und nicht diese Kontinuierlichkeit, von einem Tag zu dem anderen. Heute machen wir das gleich als gestern, aber nur etwas mehr oder etwas größer. Das ist nicht mein Ding. Aber die letzte paar Jahre von Xs4All kamen dann die Breitbandprovider. Es würde klar, das KPN bietet demnächst ADSL an. Es gab Breitband im Kabel. Das Kabelfernsehen in Amsterdam wurde dann umgebaut, dass man da auch Internet drüber machen konnte. Die ersten Modems dafür kamen. Wir hatten natürlich alle die User, die wirklich Ahnung hatten. Es gab da auch eine Menge anderer Dial-in-Provider, so in 97, 96, 97. Aber wir hatten die User, die wirklich Ahnung hatten. Wir konnten da auch Fragen beantworten von Leuten, die mal ein ganzes Topnetz routiert haben wollten oder die eigene Server betreiben wollten. Bei uns hatte jeder Ahnung. Wer bei uns als Helpdesker gearbeitet hatte, der ist dann irgendwo anders, war er gleich Leiter der Technikabteilung. Der war Systemdesigner. Weil bei uns als Helpdesker hatte man mehr Ahnung als irgendwo anders als Systemdesigner oder Netzdesigner oder was auch immer. Dann haben wir aber realisiert, gerade die User wollen alle Breitband. Und um für uns Breitband zu machen, heißt entweder, dass wir den ganzen großen Kampf angehen, um Co-Location beim Post machen zu können für ADSA, oder wir brauchen das Kabelnetz. Damals hat die Kabelnetz-Provider versucht, ob sie uns nicht kaufen konnten, aber die wollten dafür eigentlich gar nichts zahlen. Naja, dieser Streit, ob wir dann vielleicht in den Telekom Co-Location machen konnten, das ist dann später viele gelungen, und die haben dann auch ADSA angeboten, aber bei uns wären dann alle User schon weg gewesen. Also wir hatten eigentlich keine Wahl, außer wir treiben 100 Millionen Gulden zusammen und machen diese ganze politische Sache mit ADSA.
Von daher war dann Verkaufen eigentlich die logische Konsequenz.
Das war die logische Konsequenz. Es geht sowieso nicht weiter, so wie wir jetzt machen. Und das einzige Weitergehen ist jetzt, dass wir entweder 100 Millionen auftreiben. Naja, das war zu dem Zeitpunkt echt nicht realistisch. Wir waren Freaks und wir hatten gerade mal mit 1 Million gespielt, weil wir mal 1 Million geliehen hatten um unsere Pop-Infrastruktur, also Einwahlpunkte in aller Städte zu bauen. In Holland war auch noch das mit dem Tarif nochmal anders. Der Grund, dass es in Deutschland so viel weniger Internet am Anfang gab, war, dass die ganze Ortsnetze, die ganze Tarifstruktur anders war. Hier war der Druck viel mehr sich lokal einzuwählen. Und zwar sehr viele lokale Knoten.
Warum jetzt?
Weil es einfach 100 Kilometer weiter einwählen schon echt teuer war in Deutschland. Und in Holland waren die Tarife anders, weil das Land ist viel kleiner. Und man konnte mit so drei, vier Einwahlpunkte, konnte man 60, 70 Prozent der Bevölkerung gegen Lokaltarif bedienen.
Also der Unterschied zwischen Ortstarif und Ferntarif war nicht so groß wie in Deutschland?
War nicht so groß wie in Deutschland und das Ortstarif war auch echt niedrig. Am Anfang war das auch so, dass man so lange einwählen könnte, wie man wollte, für einmal Geld. Das hat sich dann irgendwann geändert, weil das war dann...
Das war ja in Deutschland nur in Berlin so. Also in Westberlin war das nur so und sonst war es halt immer teuer. Da muss ich an der Stelle auch nochmal kurz...
Aber das war also in Deutschland... War also zu dem Punkt, dass bei uns das Internet groß würde, gab es in Deutschland ein echt ausgebautes Netz von Mailboxen.
Ich muss mal kurz nochmal, bevor ich das wieder vergesse, also wen sozusagen in diesen Aspekt interessiert, der sollte dann vielleicht auch nochmal bei Chaos Radio Express 100 rein. Dann habe ich mich mit Hans unterhalten, Hans Hübner. So über diese Zeit sozusagen aus der deutschen Perspektive. Das passt jetzt hier nur gerade ganz rein. Jetzt bin ich auch schon wieder ruhig. Aber ich will ja immer... Man muss ja auch immer auf seine eigenen Sendungen verweisen.
Ja, das war gerade ein Hyperlink.
Genau, ein Hyperlink. Aber wie war es denn? Man hat ja gesagt, dass dich von Anfang an eigentlich immer Technik und Politik interessiert hat. Das ist so Internetzugang. Das hat dann natürlich so eine gewisse gesellschaftspolitische Komponente. Das sagt ja schon der Name Xs4All. Es war euch ja auch, sagen wir mal, ein Anliegen, Internetzugang überhaupt zu verbreiten, damit die Leute ihn hatten. Das war ja jetzt nicht... Also auch, aber nicht primär und nur ein Business-Modell, sondern es ging ja...
Nee, dass es ein Business wurde, das ist zwei Jahre später. Erst anderthalb bis zwei Jahre später. Es war für uns eher... Dieses Ganze, dass wir das für Geld verkauft haben, war, um das irgendwie bezahlen zu können. In 1993 kam auch das erste Computerkriminalitätsgesetz in Holland. Vorher war Hacking komplett legal. Konnte man alles machen, war komplett egal. Und dann kam da das erste Gesetz und bis 1993 hatten wir eigentlich alle Internet über nicht mehr benutzte Universitätsaccounts. Da gab es auch so informelle Provider mit das Weitergeben von diese Accounts. Da gab es auch schon diese ganze informelle Provider-Geschichte. Du kannst meinen Account benutzen.
Ah, verstehe. So eine Ertauschbörse.
So eine Ertauschbörse mit Uni-Accounts. Das war unser Internet-Provider, bevor wir selber Internet hatten. Dann hatten wir noch eine Weile ein paar Accounts über Freunde bei der Uni, die also wirklich legal waren. Aber die meisten von uns hatten illegales Internet. Und das müsste sich in 1993 auch ändern, weil wir genau wussten, wir sind da am ersten dran. Wenn die irgendwo vorbeikommen, ist hier. Also illegales Einwählen im Internet nur so um Mail und News zu haben, das geht jetzt wohl nicht mehr.
Es war auch eine Eigenlegalisierung sozusagen.
Die Interesse war, da das Geld irgendwie wiederzubekommen, damit es uns nicht pleite macht. Und Internet damit wir nicht im Knast gehen. Das war eher so die Motivation für Xs4All die ersten anderthalb Jahre, als dass es überhaupt ein Business war.
Aber du hast ja auch anfangs gesagt, dich hat schon immer Technik und Politik sozusagen in dem Kontext eng miteinander verbunden, auch von Anfang an interessiert. Was war denn in dieser Zeit, hattet ihr denn einen messbaren Einfluss auf die holländische Gesellschaft, mit dem ihr das gemacht habt? Oder war das einfach nur so, okay, es wurde so in den Medien berichtet und die Journalisten hatten irgendwie eine lustige Story?
Ja, es hat einen großen Einfluss. Es gab das Kommen von Hektik in 1993, dann gab es Digitale Stadt Anfang 94, dann gab es VPRO, das ist bei uns eine öffentlich-rechtliche Sender-Vereinigung. Die haben dann auch eine Menge Sachen im Internet gemacht, die haben angefangen, da Nachrichten zu machen und angefangen, da Kultur zu betreiben ins Internet, in 94 auch schon. Und diese Dinge zusammen haben gemacht, dass in Holland das Internet wahrgenommen wurde als öffentlicher Raum. Die erste Assoziation, die die Leute hatten bei Internet, ist, da ist öffentlicher Raum, da können wir alle was machen. Dann gab es in 96, gab es den Kampf gegen Scientology, auch nochmal, wobei die Scientology-Kult dann Informationen aus dem Internet raus haben wollte, die bei uns ein User ins Netz gestellt hatte. Und das war dann auch nochmal eine riesen Aufmerksamkeit, weil die hatten dann eine zivile Hausdurchsuchung bei uns im Haus. Da waren dann also amerikanische Colten-Mitglieder, liefen bei uns im Büro rum und haben dann diese Informationen vom Server entfernen wollen. Da haben wir irgendwo ein Büro-PC angezeigt und gesagt, ja das ist der Server. Die waren so echt dumm, wie geht nicht mehr. Aber das hat dann auch nochmal eine riesen Aufmerksamkeit gegeben in Holland. Aber Internet hat in den holländischen Medien und auch in den holländischen Aufmerksamkeit war das ein Platz, ein Ort, wo man sein Ding machen konnte.
Also sozusagen eine positive Konnotation.
Ganz positive Konnotation, auch von Hacker im Allgemeinen. Das sind die Leute, die uns das Internet gebracht haben. Das sind die Leute, die... Das war ein richtiger Zeitpunkt, wo das alles ganz positiv wahrgenommen wurde. Obwohl da vielleicht der Nachrichtendienst eine Bedenken hatte, weil da sind ja alle so, die kennen wir schon eine Weile. Aber ganz positiv wahrgenommen. Politiker wollten mit uns reden, wollten alle wissen, wo es lang geht. Da gab es eine Menge Evangelisation in Richtung Politik und in Richtung Medien. Und die wollten alle nur wissen, okay, jetzt ist das jetzt groß. Die Phase, dass wir nur als, wie lange sitzt du dann hinter dem Rechner, war klar und offenbar vorbei. Aber das Internet war in, sagen wir mal, 95, 96, als das hier in Deutschland erst richtig anfing, schon echt ein wahrgenommenes öffentlichem Raum, wo Leute sie selber darstellen konnten. Und ich glaube im Ausland, wo ich es wahrgenommen habe, in Deutschland und noch ein Jahr später auch in Frankreich, war Internet eher ein Produkt. Ein Ding, was im Fernsehen war, dass man das kaufen konnte. Es kam aus Amerika, man muss es haben. Es war ein Produkt und nicht so sehr ein Raum, was sich die Leute selber pioniert haben und was von uns kam. Und das war in Holland schon. Das ist schon Anfang der Internet-Historie und auch wie das Internet jetzt in die Köpfe rein ist.
Und hatte das auch für die politische Dimension jetzt eine Auswirkung?
Ja klar, es gab viele Politiker, die bei uns in 1996, nicht die Mehrheit natürlich, die in 1996, 1997 schon einige Ahnung hatten, was man da regulieren kann und was nicht. Und es gab schon öffentliche Meinungen, dass man das nicht überregulieren müsste. Und dass man da vielleicht vorsichtig rangehen müsste. Diese öffentliche Meinung war schon in 1996. Diese Debatte war schon in 1996 voll da.
Ich meine jetzt gar nicht so sehr die Politik im Bezug auf das Internet. Sondern sozusagen jenseits des Internets. Ich meine, wenn wir über Hacking reden, wenn wir über Politik reden, Gesellschaft reden, dann reden wir ja sozusagen auch über politische Themen, jetzt über die Technik hinaus. Die Freiheit des Einzelnen, Offenheit und Transparenz einer Gesellschaft, diese Themenlage, die jetzt sozusagen mal abgehoben ist von der eigentlichen Technik. Konntet ihr das auch transportieren?
Ja, das gab es in Holland, gab es in, ich glaube, 2696, da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher, gab es eine parlamentarische Untersuchung nach Missstände bei der Polizei, weil die Polizei da ziemlich groß selber in Kokain gehandelt hat und zwar containerweise. Da war so ein Auftrag zu der Top der kriminellen Organisationen durchzudringen und das ist denen gelungen. Etwas zu gut gelungen, sagen wir mal. Chef, wir sind zu dem Top durchgedrungen, wir sind jetzt der Top. Da waren Polizisten unterwegs mit Kofferngeld und haben sich selber, also für die Organisation natürlich, Autos von diesem Geld gekauft, was alles nicht so richtig administriert wurde. Das waren dann Zettelchen in der Tasche, Koffern mit Geld, die alles nicht so richtig administriert wurden. Da waren einige Überschneidungen zwischen Polizeiorganisationen und kriminellen Vereinigungen, sagen wir es mal so. Das hat dann eine parlamentarische Untersuchung nach Polizeimethoden gegeben. Und da gab es ein Report, ein dickes Buch, was da so alles geforscht wurde und was da entdeckt wurde. Und dieses Buch konnte man dann kaufen für 600 Gulden, obwohl es vom Parlament kam. Und da gab es auch ein CD-ROM dazu, das war dann noch 1000 Gulden. Dann hatte man auch das CD-ROM, dann konnte man das professionell benutzen als Journalist. Da hatte man Fulltext Search auf dem PC CD-ROM. Dann haben wir den PC CD-ROM genommen, das alles, die Daten runtergenommen. Das Copyright lag ja nur bei der Verfassung. Diese Verfassung hat Copyright, das ist vom SDU, unserer damals selbstständig gemachten Bundesdruckerei-Äquivalent, herausgegeben. Und wir haben den CD-ROM genommen. Und wir haben da quasi einen Ausdruck gemacht auf einen Dummiedrucker, das war ein HTML-Druckertreiber. Und haben den HTML dann einigermaßen umgebaut, damit es ging, und ins Internet gestellt. Jetzt umsonst frei. Und da konnte SDU, weil wir deren Layout nicht mitgenommen hatten, nur das Report genommen hatten, nur der Content, konnten die nichts machen. Und das haben dann alle Journalisten komplett uns die Himmel rein geschrieben. Das ist jetzt toll, das muss jetzt gemacht werden. Also diese Debatte soll diese Information jetzt öffentlich zugänglich sein, weil wir haben ja Internet, gab es in 96 voll. Und auch mit dem Scientology-Sachen, das war eine Diskussion, die hat sich darüber gehandelt, muss diese Information jetzt zugänglich sein, welche Rechte haben wir, Informationen aus der Öffentlichkeit rauszuhalten. Solche Diskussionen gab es bei uns in 96.
Das Scientology-File, vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen konkreter. Was war das beanstaltete Angebot?
Es gab ein Amerikaner, Stephen Fishman, und dieser Stephen Fishman war ein Ex-Scientologist. Und in seinem Gerichtsprozess gegen Scientology hat Scientology dann geklämt, er war gar kein Scientology und schon mal gar kein höherer Scientologist. Und dann, um zu beweisen, dass er das war, hat er in seinem Gerichtsverfahren als Dokumente von seiner Seite die ganze höhere Scientology-Texte eingebracht. Die OT-Levels, die Texte, die für Scientology heilig sind und die man nur anschauen darf, wenn man höhere Levels erreicht hat. Und die eigentlich in immer größerem Ausmaß zeigen, dass der Herbert verrückt war. Dass der Herbert durchgeknallt war. Und dass das einfach ein einigermaßen psychotischen, fehlgeschlagener Science-Fiction-Writer war. Aber das würde man so langsam erzählen, dass man eigentlich zu dem Zeitpunkt selber auch schon durchgeknallt war. Das war so der Selection-Prozess. Und die waren dann plötzlich alle öffentlich im Netz. Und das hat Scientology, die haben da, die sind da, Scientology kann man antrauen, immer vor Gericht zu gehen. Immer, die machen eins kaputt dadurch, dass sie mehr Kohle haben. Und einfach dich vor Gericht kaputt machen, dadurch, dass du dich immer verteidigen musst.
Und das haben sie aber bei euch nicht geschafft.
In Holland ist das sowieso, in Deutschland auch, ist das sowieso weniger möglich als in Amerika. Man kann jemand auch mit Unmengen an Geld nicht so einfach kaputt machen, als wie es in Amerika geht. Man macht in Amerika einfach 50 klagenden, 50 Staaten. Und wenn man dann ein paar Millionen auf die Rechnung hat und es interessiert einem nicht, dass die dann da verloren gehen, dann ist man als Gegner schon schwer dran. Und das ist in Holland und in Deutschland auch, ist das einfach schwieriger. Also die sind vor Gericht gegangen gegen uns, weil wir ja die Herausgeber waren. Und wir haben gesagt, hör mal, das ist ein Homepage. Das ist genauso wie ein Hausmieter, wenn ein Poster fürs Fenster hängt, da hat man als Vermieter auch nicht irgendwie, kann man nicht eingreifen und sagen, das ist unser Haus. Sie dürfen da nicht diesen politischen Poster fürs Fenster hängen. Wenn Sie da ein Anliegen haben, dann bitte wenden Sie sich zu diesem User und nicht zu uns. Und übrigens haben wir keine Ahnung, wie das ist und wollen wir auch nicht erzählen, bis da ein Richter sagt, dass wir das sollen. Und das hat Phosphorology natürlich versucht und die haben das weitergetrieben. Das hat zehn Jahre gedauert, dieses Prozess, bis es dann beim Hochrat, unser Bundesverfassungsgericht oder Bundesgerichtshof äquivalent war. Und dann haben Xs4All gewonnen, zehn Jahre später. Dann war es also 2006, war schon lange nicht mehr da, war schon KPN und alles. Aber dann, Xs4All hat das erst zehn Jahre später gewonnen. Aber das hat, ich glaube, das hat Xs4All insgesamt, glaube ich, 100.000 Euro gekostet, 120.000, 130.000 Euro, die ganze Sache. Aber wenn man mal betrachtet, was das an Werbung kostet hätte, so viel gute Presse zu bekommen, dass die Werbung wert davon war Millionen.
Ja, Xs4All hatte ja eigentlich früher den Ruf, da sehr standhaft zu sein, gerade was eben so diese Haftungsfragen von Inhalten betrifft, gab ja auch ein Fall mit Deutschland, mit dieser linken oder linksradikalen Zeitschrift namens Radikal, die ja auch auf einer Xs4All-Homepage...
Das kam dann später, ja, das war glaube ich 1997. Da war eine Herausgabe vom Zeitschrift Radikal, war auch wieder auf einer Non-User-Homepage und die deutschen Behörden wollten das runterhaben. Haben uns dann aufgerufen, das wegzuholen, war ja illegal.
Mit welcher Argumentation?
Na ja, war illegal. Sie dürfen das nicht verbreiten, weil es ist illegal. Wir haben gesagt, na ja, es ist illegal in Deutschland, wir sind aber nicht in Deutschland, wir sind in Holland. Wir bitten um Verständnis, dass wenn wir das machen, dann kommen morgens Saudi-Arabien und wollen alles, wo man Arme sieht oder wollen die weghaben. Wir können ja nicht mit jedes Land, und das hat sich dann überhaupt nicht gefallen, dann haben die angefangen, über die deutschen Netze dazu zu bewegen und eigentlich zu zwingen, die Xs4All-IP-Nummer zu sperren. Dann hat Xs4All die IP-Nummer immer gewechselt, weil wir hatten ja eine Menge, also immer auf neue IP-Nummer gezeigt. Als die dann angefangen haben, über mehr zu sperren, also immer mehr Zugehänge, immer mehr Kollateralschaden bei Xs4All, weil uns war das ja egal, dass dann die ganzen Deutschen nicht auf allerhand anderen Seiten zugreifen konnten. Das war ja für uns publizitär nur gut. Da konnten wir die erzwingen, das zu lassen. Und dann gab es plötzlich 20, 30, 50 mehrer, also andere Sites im Internet, die das dann auch gemacht haben. Radikal war plötzlich auch in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit wieder ganz bekannt.
Das hätte wahrscheinlich sonst keinen Menschen interessiert.
Es hätte sonst keinen Menschen interessiert. Diese Herausgabe von Radikal war die Herausgabe, wo drin stand, wie man Züge zu Stillstand bringt. Das waren die ersten Castor-Transportgeschichten. Aber das war ein Artikel und der Rest war komplett nicht durchzukommen. Hatte jetzt Rosa Luxemburg recht, wenn sie so richtig tief politische Diskussionen im radikalen Raum, die überhaupt für mich, ich hab das versucht zu lesen, ich kam da nicht mal durch, komplett uninteressant. Und plötzlich war Radikal so das große Ding, wo alle das lesen müssten und alle sich das im Internet runtergeladen haben. Das war komplett, was wir jetzt das Barbara Streisand-Effekt nennen, das war komplett einmal durchs Internet, so kontraproduktiv, wie es nur geht. Und die Sache hat sich dann lange, die Bundesanwaltschaft für Terrorismusangelegenheiten hat sich das lange noch als Sache erforscht und angenommen. Gegen den Vorstand von Xs4All ist noch bis 2000 hinein vorgegangen. Also diese Sache hat noch jahrelang, obwohl die Sperre schon längst weg war, und es auch politisch schon längst klar war, dass man das so nicht machen muss, und dass man da im Ausland diesen Einfluss nicht nehmen kann, und dass man das auch vergessen muss, dass das überhaupt geht. Das war schon längst klar, als die Bundesanwaltschaft das noch weiter verfolgen müsste. Wir können das ja nicht einfach sein lassen, Grund. Und die haben dann in 99 und 2000, ich glaube, das war 2000, als ich dann in Amsterdam vernommen worden bin, ich habe zu dem Zeitpunkt in Berlin gelebt, in Niederschönhausen. Das wussten die aber nicht, weil ich war nicht gemeldet. Dann habe ich also in Amsterdam war ich dann eingeladen worden, um im Rahmen einer Rechtshilfeanfrage vernommen zu werden, in unsere Strafding, weil wir da in Deutschland ja verdacht waren, für Beihilfe einer Werbung einer terroristischen Organisation und oder Beihilfe der ernsthaften Gefährdung des Bahnverkehrs. Also schon ein schwerer Verbrechen, wo man schon mal einen Anwalt mitbringen muss und so. Und dann bin ich also in Amsterdam extra von Berlin angereist, um dann in Amsterdam beim Untersuchungsrichter vernommen zu werden von einer Dame vom Bundesanwaltschaft für Terrorismusangelegenheit und einem Herrn vom Bundeskriminalamt. Und haben also gesagt, na ja, die gleiche Geschichte. Wir haben festgestellt, dass es in Holland nicht strafbar ist. Und im weiteren Überwogen, wenn wir dieses Präzident so machen, dass dann auch Saudi-Arabien kommen kann. Und dass wir da nicht irgendwie zwischen gute und schlechte Länder. Und dass wir also gesagt haben, für uns ist das holländische Gesetz das einzige. Was wollt ihr eigentlich? Und dann sind die wieder nach Hause gegangen. Und dann ist das Verfahren irgendwann eingestellt worden. Dann habe ich so einen Brief bekommen, sie sind offiziell kein Terrorist. Oder zumindest können wir es nicht beweisen.
Wie hat denn das die holländische Öffentlichkeit aufgenommen, diesen Vorfall? Ich meine...
Ja, die waren alle auf unserer Seite. Wir haben das einfach erklärt, dass das nicht... Dass wenn das illegal sein soll, dass das bitte das holländische Parlament uns das erzählen soll, dass das illegal ist. Und bis wir da von holländischen Richtern und holländischen Gesetzgebern was hören, dass wir das bitte ignorieren. Und die waren natürlich alle auf unserer Seite. Das war... Zu dem Zeitpunkt war Amsterdam und war Holland stolz auf, dass wir da die Freiheit hatten, alles zu lesen, was wir wollten. In Deutschland gab es zu dem Zeitpunkt echt ziemlich streng den Zuhörgesetz. Es gab eine Menge Bücher und eine Menge Zeitschriften, die man in Deutschland nicht kaufen und nicht lesen dürfte. Das soll doch mal gesagt werden. Das war nicht alle Deutsche zu dem Zeitpunkt so bekannt, wie groß das war. Außerhalb so dieser linke Szene war nicht bekannt, dass es da so schon ein Bücherschrank an Sachen gab, die einfach mal illegal erklärt wurden. Das hat sich mit Internet auch geändert, was man da illegal machen kann. Aber es gab eine Menge Wissen, was man in Deutschland einfach mal nicht haben wollte. Und in Amsterdam, gerade in der Hausbesitzer-Szene, gab es so Bücherladen, die mal ein Wand Deutschland hatten. Für alle Deutsche, die hier sind und die mal kaufen wollen, was es in Deutschland nicht zu kaufen gibt. Da gab es so einen Bücherschrank bei Ford von Scharkow und bei all dieser linke Buchladen, Royerad in Utrecht. Da gab es schon eine Menge. Da, wo wir auch die Hektik verkauft haben, war auch immer ein Schrank mit deutschen Büchern.
Alles, was verboten ist.
Alles, was verboten ist in Deutschland.
Eine wunderbare Auswahl dann eigentlich auch. Da hat man das dann auf einen Zugriff. Ja, das ist ja auch mal wieder das Problem bei diesen ganzen Zensur-Maßnahmen. Eine bessere Leseliste als was denn vielleicht mal interessant sein könnte. Als so eine Zensur-Liste gibt es ja gar nicht.
Genau.
Ja, 98 bist du dann raus bei Xs4All, hast du gesagt, oder?
Ja, 97 eigentlich schon. Nach der HIP Hacking in Progress, das war dann der nächste Event nach Hacking at the End of the Universe. Auf einem anderen Campingplatz, aber auch da in der Nähe in Holland.
Da hatte sich ja schon eine Menge getan in den vier Jahren, ne?
Da hatte sich eine Menge getan. Da war Internet plötzlich an Massendings. Da waren nicht nur Leute hingetrimpt und mit zugekommen, sondern da hatten auch mal Leute eigenen Autos. Und da hat sich eine Menge getan in diesen vier Jahren.
Ja, das hat man auch schon an der Internetversorgung gemerkt. Wo wir vorher mit den zwei Wackelmodems mal so ein bisschen Internet schnuppern durften, gab es da schon, was war das, 6 Megabit Funkstrecke?
Ja, da war eine Funkstrecke vom KPN in Benutzung. Da gab es Telefonzellen, wo dann auch gehackt wurde und umsonst angerufen wurde auf einmal.
War das an den Telefonzellen, die da schon standen, oder haben die die für diese Veranstaltung dahingestellt?
Haben die für die Veranstaltung dahingestellt.
Und das war dann nicht so eine gute Idee?
Nee, da gab es dann Zwischenfälle mit mit umsonst anrufen.
Ja, das war natürlich auch eine kernige Veranstaltung. Ich weiß noch, es war sehr heiß, aber es war auch eine extreme Aufbruchstimmung zu merken. Ich meine, die war im Prinzip schon bei der ersten Veranstaltung, bei HEU war das eigentlich auch schon da. Alle, die da hinkamen, fanden das irgendwie toll und gut. Und zwar irgendwie schön. Man war gerne da. Das war dann aber bei der HIP irgendwie auch nochmal intensiver, auch weil ja schon die Internetwelle jetzt sozusagen offiziell eröffnet war. Also vorher war das noch so ein bisschen das Randthema, auch wenn es, wie wir gehört haben, in Holland schon ein bisschen populärer war. Aber in Deutschland brachen ja die Dämmer auch erst so 95. Dann kamen irgendwie Windows 95, etc., all diese ganzen Begleitumstände. Und dann 1997 war das ja dann auch schon irgendwie alles klar. In die Richtung geht es hin. Und dann war ja auch festzustellen, dass so die Hackerkultur als solche auch auf einmal ganz anders wahrgenommen wurde. Also bekannt war man schon, ich war immer mit diesem Robin Hood Image unterwegs und gerne gehört. Aber das war zumindest so meine Wahrnehmung damals, dass eben auch so ein neuer Zulauf stattfand von jungen Leuten, die sich jetzt auch kreativ mit Technologie auseinandersetzen wollten. Und auf einmal wuchs das Ganze an. HIP war auch schon riesig groß, wie viele Leute waren da noch? Weißt du das noch? Das waren auch schon 1500 oder so.
Ja, so etwas weniger glaube ich. Etwas über 1000, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Wie war das so? Du warst ja auch noch voll in die Organisation eingebunden damals.
Na ja, schon heftig. Das war das erste Mal, dass das echt eine eigene Logistik hatte von Umfang. Dass da nicht vielleicht mal ein Lastwagen vorbeikam, sondern dass da morgens am Tag minus 2 mal 20 Laster waren, mit Zelte, mit Generatoren. Ich hab das alles lernen müssen, während das schon ging. Während das schon lief. Logistik, die ganzen Sachen sind bei uns... Als wir das mit Hacking at the End of the Universe gemacht haben in 1993, hat sich noch nie eine Veranstaltung organisiert. Außer die Electric Hacker Party. Aber das war in einem Gebäude, und damals hat Karoline Nevejern und die Paradiso-Organisation selber das meiste an Logistik übernommen. Ich war da nur für die Inhalte ein bisschen mit zuständig. Aber für nichts anderes. Und plötzlich war ich da Logistik-Organisator. Und das war schon hart. Da haben wir schon einiges auch the hard way gelernt.
Kann ich nur nicken.
Aber war lustig zu sehen, dass das wächst. Und dass wir mehr werden. Ich habe das immer für positiv empfunden. Weil wenn man politische Sachen versucht zu thematisieren und man wird nicht mehr, dann macht man was falsch.
Aber das war so.
Und die Themen waren zentraler. Es kamen mehr Leute hin, die auch verstanden hatten, dass da was Politisches abgeht. Für eine Weile ist die Movement eigentlich immer weniger technisch geworden. Anfang 90er Jahre war das nur noch Techniker. Nur noch Leute, die auch sehr viele Leute, die nur Techniker waren, die nur das interessant fanden, irgendwie zu spielen mit Netze und irgendwie. Mittlerweile besteht unser Movement aus Leute, die nicht nur Techniker sind, die es auch interessant finden, was da alles im Netz abgeht und was politisch passiert. Die auch diese ganze soziale und politische Ebene interessiert. Und Leute, die nur Techniker sind und sogar aus Computer Club kommen, entweder man kriegt was davon mit oder man könnte eigentlich auch für eine Firma nur Netze bauen. Und das Hinkommen zum Kongress zum Beispiel, das Hinkommen in diese Movement-T-Design hat auch eine politische Komponente. Das war 1990 eindeutig noch nicht so. Die führenden Mitglieder, wenn man so sagen will, hatten zwar dieses Interesse und hatten dieses Drive, aber die meisten anderen, so wie ich es mir erinnere, einfach nicht. Das kam erst später.
Wie war denn aus deiner Sicht das Verhältnis zum Club über die Jahre? Wie hat sich denn das so verändert? Du warst Ende der 18er-Jahre auf dem Kongress, hast du erzählt.
Ich habe mich immer mittendrin gefühlt. Ich habe mich immer teilgefühlt. Für diesen anderen Holländer, die dahin kamen, war das nicht so. Die haben sich immer als Besucher von irgendetwas anderes gefühlt. Erst später fühlten sie sich drin. Aber ich habe mich ab 88 direkt mit drin gefühlt. Ich war auch in 89 schon eine Woche vorher da auf dem Kongress, um zu helfen, da die Kabel zu ziehen. Weil ich das einfach so toll fand, ich wollte da jeder Tag dabei sein. Ich war da beim Eidelstädter Bürgerhaus, wo die ersten Kongresse waren in Hamburg. Drei Tage vorher lief ich auf dem Dach, um eine Telefonleitung zu ziehen. Ich habe den Club immer als meins empfunden. Der Club ist ja in den Airfahrkreisen organisiert. Und Amsterdam war da immer so ein komischen Airfahrkreis, die kein Airfahrkreis war und wo keine Mitglieder waren. Das hat immer so eine komische Rolle, aber Teil waren wir schon immer, glaube ich.
Na gut, ich meine, wie man das dann im Einzelnen so nennt, das spielt ja letztlich auch keine Rolle. Aber wie hat ja sozusagen, also ich meine, inwiefern hat sich der Stil des Clubs dann auch auf euch abgefärbt? Oder ist Holland dann so anders mit den Themen oder mit der inneren Organisation oder wie die Leute überhaupt zusammenarbeiten oder sich als eins verstehen? Also ist das irgendwie vergleichbar oder gibt es da nennenswerte Unterschiede? Ich meine, so was wie so ein CCC hat sich ja jetzt so in Holland nie herausgebildet.
Nee.
Zum Beispiel.
Naja, so die, man könnte sagen, Stereotypen sind wohl da. Deutsche sind überorganisiert, haben diese Organisation auch, muss man sagen, früh gebraucht, weil es da schon Hausdurchsuchungen gab. Und schon man als Einzelperson in Deutschland halt solche Sachen nicht machen konnte, weil dann wäre man irgendwann mal verhaftet. Oder man müsste sich schon zusammenbinden in eine ziemlich feindliche Umgebung. Die deutschen Behörden Ende der 80er konnten auch nicht richtig umgehen mit so Leute, die sich so verhalten haben. Man fühlte sich in Deutschland echt gefährdet. Man müsste zusammen sein, um nicht irgendwie angegriffen zu werden. Als ich zu dem Zeitpunkt über die Grenze gefahren bin, dann wusste man schon, hier ist Gefahr. Hier muss man aufpassen mit Drogen. Auf dem Kongress gab es Filme, wo die Filme auch mal geräumt wurden. Da kam dann Polizeieinsatz. Da gab es diese Spannung zwischen Polizei und Behörden einerseits und Club andererseits. Das gab es in Holland überhaupt zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht. Das war 1993, bis die ersten Gesetze kamen. Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten wir da komplett Freiraum. Das war in Deutschland nicht. Man fühlte sich unfreier. Im Erdestetter Bürgerhaus war so diese, ob es jetzt Bullen im Haus waren oder nicht. Da gab es auch immer so ein Warnsystem, dass die Mitglieder, die dann wussten, was dann zu passieren hatten und wo der Anwalt ist. Diese Infrastruktur gibt es bis heute. Als Julian Assange von WikiLeaks mal auf dem Kongress war und es gab eine Chance, dass ihm die Bundesnachrichtendienst wegen irgendwas mit Telefonnummern oder IP-Adressen haben wollte, da gab es schon so eine Geschichte. Dann sieht man die gleiche Infrastruktur. Dann ist plötzlich Andy in der Nähe vom Podium mit Fotogerät. Dann sitzt der Anwalt da und der sitzt da. Diese ganze Infrastruktur, sich in eine feindliche Umgebung anzuhaben, ist beim Kongress einfach immer noch da. Man weiß, was zu tun ist, wenn mal Polizei da ist oder wenn mal was passiert. Das ist aus dieser Zeit gewachsen. Mittlerweile ist es so, dass ich mich frei fühle, wenn ich über die Grenze nach Deutschland fahre. Wenn ich näher in Deutschland bin, kann man nicht mehr plötzlich angehalten werden und durchsucht. Mittlerweile ist in Holland eine Menge aus dem Ruder gelaufen, politisch.
Das hast du bei vielen Gelegenheiten auch in deinem Blog immer mal wieder beklagt. Dass dir der Lauf, den die holländische Gesellschaft so genommen hat in den letzten Jahren, nicht mehr zusagt, mal zurückhaltend formuliert. Was ist denn passiert, was ist denn los? Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen noch das alte Bild, das freie Holland, das liberale Holland, das tolerante Holland.
Das Bild kannst du wegwerfen, das Bild ist nicht mehr zutreffend. Was ist schiefgelaufen? Ich glaube im Grunde, Holland ist ein Can-do Nation, wenn mal was vorbeikommt, dann machen wir das mal. Wenn mal ein neues Plan ist, dann fassen wir das alles an und machen das. Und als dann die ganzen 80er, 90er Jahren mit lass uns mal alles privatisieren und freier Markt ist gut und als das vorbeikam, haben wir das einfach gemacht. Für Selbstständigung der Schulen und jeder Schule muss sich um seine Kunden, wir nennen das ja nicht mehr Schüler oder Studenten, muss sich um seine Kunden selber kümmern und wer nicht mitkommen kann, hat ja Pech gehabt. Diese ganze Privatisierungswelle in alles, von öffentliche Verkehrsmittel bis zur Unterricht und Krankenhäuser, hat sich einfach schneller durchgesetzt bei uns. Und gerade im Unterricht, ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger Teil der Hauptkrise bei uns, gerade im Unterricht, bei der Uni gab es dann diese Bachelor-Master-Struktur, die schon ziemlich schnell gemacht wurde und wobei man dann nicht mehr finanziert würde, wenn es über vier Jahre hinausging, so jeder müsste in vier Jahren fertig sein, das hat das öffentliche Studentenleben in Holland schon in den 90er und Anfang 90er einfach gekält, gab es nicht mehr. Es gab plötzlich keine Studentenvereine mehr, es gab nichts mehr, weil die Leute müssten einfach arbeiten, weil die müssen in vier Jahren fertig sein. Also alles, was man als mal weiter gucken und mal ein breiteres Bild von der Welt bekommen, nein, wir in Holland seit Ende der 80er Jahren werden nur noch Spezialisten in einem bestimmten Bereich, wenn überhaupt, werden geliefert und nichts anderes mehr. Das, was die Industrie gerade braucht, das wird produziert am Fließband und Generalisten, die weiter denken können, gibt es bei uns weniger. Und das war bei uns, sagen wir mal, in den 80er Jahren schon fertig. Das stand schon, das war schon fertig und wir haben also schon 20 Jahre, 25 Jahre Krise im Unterricht. Weil das wird natürlich ein Race to the Bottom. Die Universitäten, die zufälligerweise in Amsterdam oder Utrecht sind, die kriegen die Studenten umsonst, weil das sind ja coole Städte, um zu wohnen. Und alles andere im Rest des Landes muss was haben für Marketing. Und das, was man hat, ist bei uns einfacher. Wir suchen die untere Grenze an, was wir legal noch als Diplom oder noch ein Bachelor oder ein Master oder einen Schulabschluss nennen dürfen. Und wir suchen immer weiter nach unten. Und diese Race to the Bottom ist in Holland jetzt completed. Du kannst jetzt eine Menge an Fachhochschule-Abschlüsse, kannst du mit einer Woche die Bücher lesen, du und ich können da Fachhochschulabschluss machen. Auf Papier sind wir nicht schlecht ausgebildet. Wenn man mal die Statistiken nachguckt, Holland ist prima ausgebildet. Keine Krise gibt es nicht. Mittlerweile versteht die Öffentlichkeit, dass wir da was falsch gemacht haben, dass es da ein Problem gibt. Aber das hilft jetzt nicht, dieses Problem zu realisieren, weil wir kommen da nicht raus, weil wir haben nicht die Leute, die ausgebildete Leute, um uns da rauszufixen. Und da gibt es noch eine Menge andere Faktoren. Holland hatte zu dem Zeit, als Deutschland die fünf neue Länder hatte und sich irgendwie neu erfinden müsste, weil jetzt gibt es wirtschaftliche, doch wohl ein bisschen schwierigere Zeiten. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt, als die Deutsche sich realisiert haben, ich muss jetzt auch wirklich selber sorgen, dass ich ausgebildet werde und ich muss selber sorgen, dass ich zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte. Holland, Erdgas, und zwar in Unmengen damals noch, und Jobs gibt es ja eh.
Also Erdgas ist jetzt eine eigene Förderung?
Ja, eigene Förderung im Nordsee und in Groningen. Unsere Wirtschaft lief ja eh, Geld ist ja eh da, Job kriege ich ja eh. Also dieser Eigenantrieb bei Leuten, sich auszubilden oder was zu lernen, war auch nicht da. Man würde faul, das ist ja der Fluch des Erdöls und in diesem Fall Erdgas ist. Man würde faul, das kommt auch noch dazu. Es gab ja die Wirtschaft von alleine. Wir hatten einen Transportsektor, der war groß, wir haben ziemlich viel Asphalt, es wird gebaut. Machen wir einfach weiter und alles ist gut. Also dieser Antrieb da mal umzustellen war auch nicht da. Mittlerweile führt das dazu, dass die Leute anfällig sind, Rechtspopulismus zu wählen.
Deswegen?
Weil einfach dieser breitere Blick, was ist jetzt los und was ist vernünftig, ist auch bei mir und mehr Leute nicht mehr da. Es gab dann auch noch ein paar Zwischenfälle. Es gab Pim Fortein, so ab 2000, 2001 gab es so einen Rechtspopulist, der formuliert hat, es gibt Probleme mit der Immigration und die gab es auch, gibt es immer noch, es ist nicht problemfrei, Leute aus aller Welt in einem Land leben zu lassen. Und dieses Problem war auch Tabu. Muss man sagen, dieses Problem war Tabu, da würde nicht drüber geredet, konnte man nicht drüber reden, weil da war man ja Rassist. Und der hat das fürs erste Mal thematisiert, er hat das auch einigermaßen vernünftig gemacht, in dem Sinne, dass er nicht, man könnte ihm nicht nachwerfen, der ist Rassist, weil der hat einfach gesagt, es gibt Probleme, da müssen wir mal darüber reden. Der Mensch war nicht so unvernünftig. Dann ist er zwei Wochen vor der Wahl, wo er projiziert war, richtig groß zu werden mit seiner Partei, Liste Pimp-Vorteil, ist er dann ermordet worden in 2002. Das hat dann die normale Lauf der Geschichte verstört. Die normale Lauf war dann, weil er mit allerhand Trottel unterwegs war. Er war selber vernünftig, halbwegs, aber er war mit tausend Trottel unterwegs. Die sind dann auch nach seinem Tod im Parlament gewählt worden und auch in die Regierung gekommen, haben sich untereinander total gestritten. Und irgendwann war die Regierung wieder weg und Neuwahlen. Hätten die sich gestritten mit ihm da, dann wäre das nicht so ein Problem. Weil dann wäre es offensichtlich, sie haben da auch die Lösungen nicht und streiten sich nur untereinander. Und jetzt war das aber die Linken, es war ja ein radikaler Aktivist, der immer Schossen hat. Die Linken haben jetzt verursacht, dass das alles nix wird, weil Pim Fortein ist ja weg. Und die normale Lauf der Geschichte war damit verstört. Ja, und dann, naja, es gab dann auch in 2001 schon 11. September und so diese Angstwelle ist dann in Holland so ein bisschen weiter getrieben worden. Es gibt ja politischen Gewalt und wir müssen jetzt alle, wir müssen Bodyguards haben und das hat das Land echt verändert. So diese politische Mord und dann gab es später noch der Mord auf Teho Fakhroch, der Filmmaker. Und so diese Sachen haben das Land echt verändert. Da plötzlich gab es diese echte Bedrohung von arabischen Terroristen, wollen uns alle tot haben und wir brauchen mehr Sicherheit, mehr Gesetze und das zusammen mit der Fakt, dass es zu wenig wirklich ausgebildete und breitschauende Menschen gab, ein echter Shortage daran. Diese Sachen zusammen haben gemacht, dass das einigermaßen aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist. Und jetzt sehen das auch viele, dass wir in Unterrichten ein Problem haben und dass wir das neu buten müssen. Das sehen jetzt auch mehrere, das ist jetzt ein öffentlicher Thema. Aber ja, zu spät.
Denkst du, dass Holland die notwendigen Selbstheilungskräfte da aufbringen kann?
Weiß ich nicht, ich befürchte nicht. Ich befürchte, dass wir erst mal 10 Jahre richtig den Bach runtergehen.
Du bist dann ja auch nach der ganzen Frühhackerzeit, kann man es ja mittlerweile schon mal nennen, so Xs4All, lag dann so hinter dir. Da hat ja alles so ein bisschen so eine andere Orientierung genommen. Das war ja auch in Deutschland nicht anders, auch für den Club. Der Kongress ist nach Berlin gegangen, das hat eine ganze Menge Änderungen mit sich gebracht für den Club. Diese gesamte Popularität der Hackerszene hat auch den Club wachsen lassen, hat das Ganze auch auf ein anderes Fundament gestellt. Mittlerweile erleben wir ja auch noch mal ein weiteres, wie soll ich sagen, eine neue Zuwendung in der Öffentlichkeit zu dem, was die Hacker so meinen. Und vor allem weniger jetzt in dieser Aufmerksamkeit für diese konkreten technischen Hacks, sondern mittlerweile wird eben sehr viel breiter diskutiert. Es wird tatsächlich über das, was wir schon immer sozusagen in die Gesellschaft geben wollten, an Grundgedanken, das wird diskutiert. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das unbedingt alles übernommen wird, aber es wird zumindest gehört, es wird aufgegriffen. Man merkt, dass jetzt auch Generationen in der Gesellschaft an allen möglichen Stellen angekommen sind, die einfach eben auch mit dieser Zeit aufgewachsen sind. Das ist zumindest so mein Eindruck. Das wird ja in Holland auch nicht anders sein. Also auch da sind ja jetzt sozusagen Leute in den 30ern, in den 40ern, die eben diese Frühzeit des Internets auch noch auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise mitgenommen haben und von daher auch ganz anders disponiert sind als eben die Generationen davor. Du hast dich ja dann sehr auf dieses Thema der Wahlcomputer gestürzt in Holland. Was war denn da sozusagen der Auslöser dafür?
Noch mal kurz zum Thema, es werden unsere Themen diskutiert und es werden unsere Themen übernommen teilweise auch. Da sind interessante Sachen noch dahinter. Ich glaube, einer der Gründe, dass wir so wichtig sind und dass wir auch so wichtig wahrgenommen werden als Community, ist, dass es offensichtlich wird, dass viele in der Politik zum Beispiel keine Antworten mehr haben. Wer mit Politikern umgeht, wer Lobby macht, ich habe das selber wegen Wahlcomputer gemacht, aber jeder, der Lobby macht aus unserer Bewegung heraus, der mit Politikern mal geredet hat, als die Mikro ab war, jeder kann das Gleiche bestätigen. Da ist da ist eine Hilfslosigkeit, eine Oh mein Gott, was passiert jetzt? Alle gehen noch davon aus, wenn wir es haben über Wirtschaft, dann wird immer davon ausgegangen, wann wird es wieder ruhig? Und ich glaube, dass wir aus unserer Geschichte heraus und aus diesem Wahrnehmen von sehr viel Information gleichzeitig und auch aus diesem Verständnis, wie so ein bisschen, dass alles sich auch selbst organisieren kann, dezentral, so Sachen, die einfach die neue Verhältnisse prägen. Aus diesem Verständnis, dass wir auch verstehen, dass es vielleicht mal nicht mehr ruhig wird und dass sich mal Sachen grundlegend geändert haben. Es gibt viele Hacker, die sich entweder interessieren für neue Trends in der Wirtschaft oder für was passiert jetzt wirklich mit dem Öl. Das war bei uns, Peak Oil war bei uns in What the Heck, eine Veranstaltung, als dann Leute gefragt haben, was ist das denn für ein Quatsch-Thema. Das war 2005, das in unserer Szene schon richtig etabliert war, ach du Scheiße, da haben wir ein Problem. Das war bei uns echt schon alt. Und in der Gesellschaft kam das an, als was ist das denn für ein Ding. Und dann genau ein Jahr später ging dann plötzlich die Ölpreise auf 200 Dollar pro Barrel. Und war jeder klar, oh, da war was, okay, verstehe. Wir haben halt an bestimmte Stellen, auch nicht immer und auch nicht überall, aber wir haben halt mal so einen breiteren Blick gehabt und mal verstanden, was das heißt, wenn alles schnell wird und dezentral und diese ganze normale dämpfende Faktoren aus der Wirtschaft und aus der Kultur und wenn die mal weg sind. Und ich glaube, dass das auch da draußen verstanden wird, dass das unser etwas breiterer Blick sich nicht begrenzt auf was für Operating System soll ich denn haben oder was für, sondern dass wir auch mal verstehen, wie die Welt vielleicht aussehen könnte. Dass wir teilweise als mögliche Architekten für neue Strukturen gesehen werden. Und das ist wichtig und das ist glaube ich auch der Grund, dass wir so groß sind im Moment. Der Grund ist nicht, dass wir uns mit Computern auskennen, sondern der Grund ist, dass es mehr und mehr Leute einsehen, dass wir einen Teil des Antworts haben.
Aber du hast dich ja dann mit den Wahlcomputersachen dann eigentlich sehr mit der holländischen Öffentlichkeit angelegt.
Ja, ich habe da wirklich mit einer kleinen Gruppe zusammen, haben wir echt politische Lobby betrieben. Und wir haben eigentlich alles gemacht, was man machen muss, um diesen Wahlcomputer loszuwerden. Da muss ich erklären, diese Wahlcomputer, wir haben da glaube ich auch schon mal ein Chaos Radio darüber gemacht.
Das gab es bei Chaos Radio, gab es das glaube ich auch. Das kann ich gleich noch mal schauen. Ich habe mit dem Ulrich Wiesner, der hier die Klage vor den Verfassungsgerichten Deutschland durchgefochten hat, CAE 118, nach dem Urteil noch mal eine ausführliche Sendung gemacht, wo das ein Thema war, wo ich finde, wo auch die ganzen Argumente, über die wir jetzt sicherlich teilweise auch noch mal reden werden, auch sollten ganz gut zusammengefasst wurden und eben auch diese spezifische deutsche Sicht auch noch mal eine Rolle gehabt hat. Es gab auch ein Chaosradio zu dem Thema, warst du da eigentlich sogar dabei? Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr.
Das glaube ich nämlich auch, dass ich dabei war, als wir mitgekommen sind.
Naja, richtig, Chaosradio 117 von 2006, September 2006.
Genau.
Genau, und nieder warst du nicht dabei.
Oder war ich am Telefon, glaube ich?
Naja, genau, wir hatten dich mit dem Telefon drin, genau, der Ulrich war im...
Genau.
Immerhin, mal kurz das Thema zusammenfassen. Wahlcomputer gab es in Holland seit den 90ern, seit Anfang 90ern gab es immer mehr. Und so in der Hälfte 2000, 2005 so war Holland ganz Wahlcomputer. Außer in einem Stadt, ganz Gallien, nein, in einem Stadt gab es noch Papierwahlen, das war Amsterdam. Dann haben die in 2005 bekannt gegeben, wir machen in 2006 die Gemeindewahlen mit Computern. Und zwar Maschinen von SDU, nicht die NEDAP-Maschinen, sondern Maschinen von SDU mit Windows und Touchscreen. Und am Ende des Tages haben die per Funkmodem das GPRS übertragen, die Wahlergebnisse. Und ich habe dann angefangen zu studieren, was ist da denn Sache? Und festgestellt, da gibt es überhaupt keine, da gab es zwar, wie heißt denn das, Spezifikationen, die öffentlichen Spezifikationen, wo dran Wahlmaschinen sein müssten. Aber die waren überhaupt nicht ausgelegt für Sicherheit. Die einzige Sicherheit, die da ausgelegt war, war halt, dass es nicht ausfällt. So Sicherheit gegen Ausfall und Sicherheit, dass man da nicht irgendwie Elektroschock bekommt, wenn man das Tastatur berührt, wenn es mal nass wird, dass es Vibrationen abkann. Aber nichts mit Sicherheit. Das konnte also ein komplett ungesicherter Windows-Kiste mit offenes GPRS-Modem sein. Das war alles egal. Hauptsache, man kriegt keinen Schock, wenn man es berührt. Das habe ich dann festgestellt, selber für mich. Und gesagt, das kann nicht sein, das muss jetzt weg.
Das heißt, du hast sozusagen in dem Wahllokal überhaupt das erste Mal selbst beim Wählen Kontakt gehabt?
Na, das war schon vorher. Das war schon vorher. Das war in 2005. Da habe ich schon festgestellt, das geht so nicht. Und dann war ich in Dezember 2005 auf dem Kongress. Da war auch Ulrich Wiesner. Und Ulrich Wiesner war Techniker, aber sein Vater war ja Jurist. Und der hat für mich das juristische und politische, was macht der Gesetzgeber, mit dem Technik verbunden. Warum ist diese Technik nicht in Übereinstimmung mit dem Grundgesetz? War zwar eine deutsche Diskussion, aber der hat auch geredet von internationalen Abkommen. Und ich habe gedacht, dass dieser Ansatz brauche ich in Holland auch. Ich muss nicht mehr nur der Technik machen, weil es handelt sich letztendlich nicht um die Technik, sondern um mangelnde Transparenz. Und das steht in Abkommen, das steht überall in Gesetze. Und da muss ich einfach mal ein bisschen breiter dran. Und da haben wir innerhalb dieses Jahr 2006 eine Menge gemacht. Da gab es also diese Gemeindewahlen. Das ist das einzige Mal, dass ich auf dem Wahlcomputer gewählt habe. Da habe ich dann diese Leute, die da saßen, die Wahlhilfe, gefragt. Sie unterschreiben doch am Abend so ein Protokoll. Und in diesem Protokoll, die Wert davon ist doch eigentlich, wir haben morgens geguckt, ob der Urner leer war. Wir haben dann einen Zettel pro Wähler reingehen sehen. Wir haben das selber umgedreht auf dem Tisch und gezählt. Und wenn hier großer Wahlbetrug war, dann haben wir das gemacht. Oder es war ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr guter Trick. Oder wir sind da schuld. Und wenn das 40.000 Leute unterschreiben, das hat einen Wert. Und jetzt unterschreiben sie doch eigentlich, wir vier Bürger haben hier so eine Kiste bekommen. Wir haben keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert. Und am Ende des Tages kam da ein Zettel raus. Da haben wir einen Bürger. Und die Anzahl von Stimmen ist richtig. Das können wir nachvollziehen, alles andere nicht. Und am Ende des Tages kam diesen Zettel raus. Und wir haben keine Ahnung, wie die zustande kamen. Und das war es. Das ist doch eine fundamental andere Wert dieser Erklärung. Und da haben mich vier Leute angeguckt und gesagt, dann habe ich noch mal geguckt und dann habe ich gesagt, das geht so nicht. Das muss sich ändern. Und dann haben wir ab diesem Sommer, das war dann im März, und ab diesem Sommer haben wir dann eine große Kampagne gemacht. Wir haben eine Kampagne, weil wir Vertrauen in STEM Computers nicht, wir Vertrauen war Computers nicht, haben wir gegründet und sind dann ziemlich groß in die Medien gegangen und haben eigentlich alle Rollen gleichzeitig gespielt. Wir waren sowohl Untersuchungsjournalisten, als Lobbyisten, als Aktivisten, als wissenschaftliche Untersucher der Technik. Wir haben alle diese Rollen gleichzeitig mit einer kleinen Gruppe gespielt. Wir haben dann so einen Wahlcomputer in der Hand bekommen, über ein Fernsehprogramm erst und dann später haben wir auch noch zwei gekauft bekommen, weil wir die Gemeinden besaßen, die ja und wir haben dann alle Gemeinden.
Was meinst du, ihr habt den über das Fernsehprogramm bekommen?
Wir haben mit dem Fernsehprogramm zusammengearbeitet und wir haben mit die zusammen gefragt bei Gemeinden, ob wir nicht so ein Ding leihen konnten, uns ans leihen konnten, um mal zu zeigen, wie das denn wirklich ist. Und die mal von einer anderen Seite zu zeigen, als Leute gewohnt waren, war die Story. Und da hat eine Gemeinde gesagt, es ist gut. Und die haben wir dann auseinandergenommen natürlich und studiert. Und dann wollten wir aber die nicht zurückgeben, mussten aber. Und dann haben wir selber noch Gemeinden gefunden, die die Dinge hatten, die zu viele davon hatten, weil sie zusammengefügt waren. Weil in Holland ist das so der Trend, Gemeinden werden größer.
Ja, dann zusammengelegt und dann brauchten sie nur noch einen.
Brauchten sie nur noch weniger. Und dann haben wir die angerufen, alle, so waren es wohl 100. Und dann haben alle angerufen und bis wir eins gefunden hatten, die uns Geräte verkauft hat, weil wir die ja brauchten für unser Betriebsrat-Wahlheim. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es vom Ministerium schon ein Schreiben, bitte, bitte passen Sie auf Ihren Wahlcomputer auf und die sollen auch niemals verkauft werden, niemals auf der freien Markt gelangen. Und dieser Brief war schon tagelang raus, aber die hatten die noch nie geöffnet bei dieser Gemeinde. Wir waren gerade so noch rechtzeitig und da haben wir Wahlcomputer bekommen und ein Paper drüber geschrieben, was eigentlich zeigte, dass mit dem Sicherheit und alles, was die Hersteller und den Hersteller nachher auch die Behörden über diese Maschine gesagt haben, ist eigentlich nicht wahr. Alles, was es an Behauptungen über Sicherheit gibt, sind alle nicht wahr. Es ist nicht nur eine nicht wahr, sondern es sind alle nicht wahr und zwar so und so und so. Wir haben auch Programme dafür geschrieben, um darauf Schach zu spielen, weil derjenige, der sie in Holland verkauft hat, hat dann gesagt, ja, das geht alles nicht. Und wir haben dann behauptet, unsere zentrale Behauptung am Anfang der Kampagne war immer, man könnte auf diese Geräte die Stimmen ehrlich zählen. Das ist durchaus möglich. Behaupten wir auch nicht, dass das nicht geht. Das können die Dinge. Genauso können die Stimmen unehrlich zählen, die können auch Schach spielen. Sie können nämlich alles, was ein Computer kann, was für uns komplett selbstverständlich war.
Der Begriff Wahlcomputer war ja an der Stelle eigentlich auch neu.
Ja, es war immer eine Wahlmaschine. Weil eine Maschine ist ja ein Single Purpose Device, so haben die das auch immer genannt. Das kann nichts anderes als eine Wahlmaschine sein. Es läuft auch kein Betriebssystem drauf. Also das mit Viren ist alles nichts. Diese Hacker können da alles behaupten, es ist gar kein Computer. Dann haben wir gesagt, es ist ein Wahlcomputer. Und dann hat der Typ, hilflicherweise, die waren total hilfreich. Also die Manufacturers waren total...
Also reden die jetzt von der Firma NEDAP?
Der Firma NEDAP und der Typ, der in Holland dann die Software dafür geschrieben hat, Jan Hrunendael. Der war mit NEDAP. NEDAP war so die Gerätebauer und Hrunendael war der Bauer der Software, der das dann für die Gemeinden dann die Briefe gemacht hat und die ganze Verwaltung hinter diese Maschinen. Und Jan Hrunendael hatte das Kontrakt, um das an die Gemeinden zu verkaufen. Und Hrunendael war dann, der war, hilfreicherweise war der ein durchgeknallter, autoritären, rechter, nicht so schlauer Mensch. Und das war sehr hiefrecht. Der hat viel mehr für unsere Kampagne getan, als wir selber hätten tun können. Der hat zum Beispiel gesagt, dass mit Schach auf unserer Maschine alles Quatsch. Das hat er ganz zentral tausendmal behauptet. Und dann haben wir so eine Maschine bekommen. Und das erste, was wir natürlich drauf haben wollten, auch um zu testen, ob wir den IO verstanden haben, war Schach drauf. Und das haben wir einigermaßen geschickt gemacht. Das war so ein großes Tastenfeld. Diese NEDAPs hatten so ein Tastenfeld von 80 x 60 cm. Oder 50 cm, so richtig groß. Und auf diesem Tastenfeld hatten wir dann das Schachbrett auch ausgelegt, damit wir dann die Stücke mit Magneten auch da draufgeklebt haben. Und da konnten wir dann auch die Stücke eindrücken auf dem Tastenfeld und dann auf die neue Position nochmal. Und das war dann unsere Eingabe auch.
Also man konnte richtig die Schachfiguren bewegen auf dem Brett?
Man könnte richtig die Schachfiguren bewegen. Es war geschickt gemacht. Es war nicht nur mit eintippen der Züge, sondern man konnte das wirklich geschickt Schach spielen. Und dann, als wir das dann im Fernsehen gezeigt haben, dann war auch mit seiner Behauptung immer wieder, dass man kann auf unsere Geräte kein Schach spielen. Und dann dieses Schachspiel drauf. Ja, dann war die ganze Diskussion auch schon...
War das nicht sogar so, dass ihr sogar selber Wahlcomputer auf die Geräte draufgeschrieben haben und noch behauptet haben, das seien keine?
Ja, sind keine Wahlcomputere, sind Wahlmaschinen. Anfang der 90er hatten die, waren die ja stolz drauf, dass es Wahlcomputer waren. Und haben das auch selber, war das auf die Tippschilder, war das drauf. Wir haben uns sogar versucht, eine Beschwerde, weil wir haben da eine Menge auch vor Gericht gemacht. Wir waren ja nicht nur alle diese Reuen, die wir dich gerade erwähnt haben, wir waren auch vor Gericht. Wir waren unsere eigenen Anwälte auch. Wir haben da 26 EFG-Anfragen geleistet, drei, vier zivile Prozeduren.
Was ist EFG?
Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Unserer Äquivalent heißt WOB., aber das ist quasi unser Äquivalent vom EFG. Wir haben, also das sind quasi Freedom of Information Requests. Zivil sind wir vor Gericht gegangen, wir haben behauptet, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, auch mit dem Gesetz, was da war und was völlig locker war und alles konnte durch. Aber auch da hatten die Fehler gemacht und auch da konnten wir zeigen, dass das stimmt überhaupt nicht mit dem, was da im Gesetz steht.
Also ihr habt nicht nur so die Medien in Bewegung gesetzt, sondern ihr habt ja eigentlich auf allen, auf breiter Front angegriffen. Juristisch, medial.
Da musst du dir vorstellen, dass wir bei den Parlamentswahlen, die dann später im November 2006 kamen, war der Panik schon so groß, da haben die dann die die die SDU-Maschinen aus dem Verkehr gezogen. Weil die könnte man abhören mit Strahlung. Also die haben Radiostrahlung erzeugt, die könnte man abhören. Aber eigentlich so als in der Hoffnung, dass wir dann das mit dem Gerichtsverfahren gegen die Maschinen überhaupt sein lassen. Wir hatten zu dem Zeitpunkt eingeschätzt, wir können das vor Gericht gewinnen. Wir können vor Gericht gehen und dann kriegen wir die ganze Wahlcomputer verboten erst mal. Das wird dann vielleicht nicht halten, aber für diese Wahl wird das reichen. Weil wir haben ausreichend stärke Argumente, dass das klappen konnte. Erst später haben wir erfahren, das war auch deren Einschätzung beim Innenministerium, dass das mal klappen konnte. Und dann gibt es keine Wahlcomputer, diese Wahl. Und weil es in Holland überhaupt kein Wissen mehr über Papier war, und es keine Wahl gab, aus Amsterdam, hätte das gehießen, die Parlamentswahlen würden dann um so sechs Monate verschoben.
Einfach aus organisatorischen Gründen?
Aus organisatorischen Gründen wäre dann die Parlamentswahl sechs Monate verschoben. Im Grundgesetz steht aber, das Parlament sitzt vier Jahre. Das wäre dann also eine Situation, die mit dem Grundgesetz nicht zu vereinigen war. Dann landet man in, was in Holland Staatsnotrecht heißt. Das ist, was man nimmt. Staatsnotrecht ist, was man nimmt, wenn mal ein Zweiten Weltkrieg war und man muss die parlamentare Demokratie neu buten.
Notstandsgesetze heißt das bei uns, glaube ich.
Wenn das passiert, wäre das passiert, dann wäre quasi unser Bundesinnenministerium equivalent das Land aus der Hand gefallen. Das wäre so der Gau. Und als wir dann angekündigt haben, wir machen dieses Prozess nicht, weil wir haben das Gefühl, wir könnten gewinnen. Und wir wollen diese Wahlen ja nicht verstören. Uns ist die Demokratie sehr lieb. Und wir wollen diese Wahlcomputer zwar loswerden, aber nicht die Wahl selber. Und als wir das angekündigt haben, gab es da im Innenministerium Partyfeier. Die Wahlen sind gerettet, wir können jetzt das Parlament wählen. Und seitdem sind wir eigentlich im Grunde mit dem Innenministerium an der gleichen Seite. Die haben gesehen, dass mit Wahlcomputern alles scheiße ist. Die Gemeinden wollen immer noch, und vielleicht kommen ja sogar neue Wahlcomputer. Weil die wollen ja irgendwas mit Paper Trail. Wir haben ja kein richtiges Grundgesetz. Also bei uns wird es diese Kampf jede 10 Jahre oder jede 5 Jahre noch mal geben müssen. Weil Grundgesetz nicht da. Und also keine verbindliche Regeln. Es gibt keinen Richter, der sagen kann, ist alles Quatsch, weg damit. Bei uns muss man das jedes Mal neu erkämpfen. Was auch irgendwie keinen Spaß macht. Aber das ist ein Problem, was größer ist bei uns. Das hat nichts mehr nur mit Wahlcomputer zu tun. Wir haben keine Grundlagen, worauf unsere Stadt gebaut ist, die wir irgendwie...
erhalten könnten.
Die wir irgendwie diese 24-hour-News-Cycle gegenüber verteidigen können. Das wird immer die gleiche Diskussion wieder neu geben, weil es keine verbindliche Grundlagen gibt. Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, als dann die Wahlen gerettet wurden, ist da danach dieses Prozess loszuwerden. Die wollten dann die Wahlcomputer halten, bis neue gebaut werden konnten. Mit Papertrail oder irgendwas. Und wir haben gesagt, nein, wird nicht passieren, die müssen jetzt weg. Und dann sind wir noch mal vor Gericht gegangen, geklagt wegen der Zulassung von diesen NEDAP-Computern und haben da gewonnen. Und in der Woche, als dann klar war, wir gewinnen das vor Gericht, haben die das selber dann eingestellt und gesagt, na ja, lassen wir sein, wir machen das jetzt mit Papierwahl. Und das war so das Gewinnmoment. Das war dann aber erst 2007, weit in, nee, 2008 sogar, in 2008 hinein war das endgültige Gewinnmoment. Jetzt ist vorbei, jetzt machen wir Papierwahl.
Das Ganze hat ja dann auch seine Auswirkungen in Deutschland gehabt. Und wie wir ja alle wissen, beziehungsweise wer es nicht weiß, der soll mal in diese andere, von mir schon erwähnte, Chaos Radio Express 118-Folge reinhören. Mittlerweile ist es ja auch in Deutschland so, dass die Geräte nicht mehr zulässig sind. Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich das hier mit den anderen Leuten zuhören kann.
Die Erkenntnis an der Stelle war, dass das gerade um das Thema Privacy zu viel gleichzeitig aus dem Ruder gelaufen war, dass wir das nicht mehr im Griff bekommen. Im Nachhinein kann man sagen, das war zu pessimistisch. Im Nachhinein kann man sagen, da ist eine Menge Gutes passiert, womit wir eigentlich nicht gerechnet haben und womit eigentlich auch zu dem Zeitpunkt sehr viele nicht gerechnet haben, muss man ehrlich sagen. Dass wir beim Bundesverfassungsgericht danach alles gewonnen haben, was es zu gewinnen gab. Mit Autokenzeichen darf man nicht einfach mal so, wie man Lust hat, mal alle im Datenbank speichern, wenn was mal vorbeifährt. Online-Desuchungen gibt es nicht. Bundestrojaner, diese ganze Geschichte. Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Wahlcomputer. Dass wir das Bundesverfassungsgericht so dermaßen an unserer Seite gefunden haben, wie es passiert ist, in 2005 hat niemand damit gerechnet. Das sah wirklich aus, als ist jetzt mit Privacy und mit ist jetzt Ende. Fängt jetzt das Ende mal an. Ich bin der Meinung, wenn Privacy weg ist, und in Holland sieht man das auch, wenn Privacy weg ist, kommt es nicht wieder, weil die Machtstrukturen danach bauen sich darauf auf, dass diese Information zur Verfügung steht. Dass man einfach mal gucken kann, wer meldet mit wem und was passiert und wer ist gerade wo im Telefonnetz mit seinem Mobiltelefon unterwegs. Ziemlich schnell, nachdem diese Information da ist, baut sich da eine Machtstruktur drauf auf. Und diese Machtstruktur wird man nicht mehr einfach los. Auch weil man ja da einen Informationsunterschied hat. Man hat diese Information nicht, und die haben diese Information schon. Also ich habe auch immer schon in den Anfang der 90er-Jahre gesagt, wir müssen aufpassen, nicht über dieser Point of No Return hinauszukommen, weil davon kommen wir nicht wieder. Wenn Privacy für alle weg ist, dann ist sie auch wirklich weg. Dann kommt sie auch nicht wieder. Und ich glaube, in Deutschland, mit dieser Bundesverfassungsgericht, diese Urteile, ist ein Raum geschaffen, wo noch was zu gewinnen ist, wo wir noch was erreichen können. In Holland mittlerweile ist Privacy echt weg. Da ist jetzt Vorratsdatenspeicherung und das komplette Programm. Die Polizei will mobile Nacktscanner, erst mal vehicle mounted und danach auch man portable. Auf der Straße mal eben ein bisschen nacktscannen. Da gibt es jetzt alles, was man so denken kann an Gesichtserkennung, einfach mal alle Autos speichern. Wir benennen jetzt da mal Notgebiete und wollen jetzt mal alle aus dem Auto raus, Papiere, wer ist dann so im Auto drin, Drogenhund durch, die Bagage dann in den mobilen X-Ray-Scanner, die wir dabei haben, und ja, okay, war nix, okay, können sie weiterfahren. Einfach mal alle, die auf die Autobahn sind da nachts. Wer ist dann so nachts auf der Autobahn unterwegs und da mal alles. Und dann auch 20 Behörden gleichzeitig. Du kannst einen hollandischen Brief empfangen, sie haben kommender Dienstag um 13 Uhr Hausbesuchung. Sind sie aber nicht alleine, das machen wir bei 20.000, 30.000 Wohnungen dieses Jahr in unserer Stadt. Weil wir wollen ja alle in einem sicheren Stadtleben. Und sie haben also Hausbesuchung. Passen Sie auf, wir müssen in alle Räume rein. Also alle Schlüsse müssen da sein, alle Bewohner. Weil wir müssen ja einfach mal rumgucken. Und das machen wir halt mal bei sie. Weil sie könnten ja dann Drogenplantation haben oder sie könnten da ja Illegalen haben. Und wir kommen einfach mal vorbei. Das kann jetzt in Holland durchaus passieren.
Aber das kündigen sie dann zumindest noch an.
Das kündigen sie dann an, ja. Wenn es so einfach mal aus dem Nichts ist, wenn es einfach mal ohne spezifischen Verdenken ist, Verdacht ist, dann geht das mit Brief. Holland ist einfach, was Bürgerrechte angeht, durchaus weiter im Eimer als die meisten Länder drum rum. Wir waren vor 20 Jahre auf dem Niveau Dänemark besser als Deutschland. Und wir sind jetzt auf dem Niveau England und nach Italien unterwegs. Muss man so sagen. Es werden bei uns mehr Telefonate abgehört als jegliches anderes Land. Wir sind, glaube ich, von aller Demokratie in der Nummer eins.
In Europa?
Nee, weltweit.
Ach wirklich?
Abgehörte Telefonate, abgefragte Lokationsdaten. Was alles angeht, sind wir die Nummer eins. Wir sind da echt downwardly mobile mit einem richtig großen Delta.
Zumindest bietet sich da für Hollywood noch eine Möglichkeit, da schöne dystopische Zukunfts-Visionsfilme zu bauen.
Ja, ist echt. In 2005 war für mich einsichtlich, da geht es in Holland hin, dass es jetzt nicht mehr zu stoppen, dass es jetzt zu spät ist. Da gab es dann auch diese ganze Terrorangst, mehr als in Deutschland noch, wegen diese zwei Mördermorden. Also ich war da auch persönlich wegen dieser ganzen Geschichte in einer ziemlichen Scheiss-Stimmung. Ist jetzt alles kacke. Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, wir haben beide, glaube ich Frank und ich, unterschätzt, dass es hier in Deutschland, dass diese Bewegung sich wirklich... Man muss hier nicht über 51 Prozent im Parlament gewinnen. Man kann ja auch vor Gericht gewinnen. Das war mir so... In dem Ausmaß, wie es hier passiert ist, war mir das nicht so klar. Dass, wenn man mit eigentlich in Anzahl kleine Bewegungen, das Verfassungsgericht hinter sich findet, dass man dann gewinnen kann und dass man Grenzen stellen kann, wo sich jetzt auch die Politiker realisieren, ja, können wir zwar wollen, aber dürfen wir vom Verfassungsgericht nicht. Dass das so stark ist. Aber ich hoffe, die Deutschen realisieren sich das, auch dagegen gibt es einen Trick. Man manipuliert das Verfassungsgericht über Jahrzehnten hinweg, dass es im Grunde genommen, was in Amerika passiert ist. Da gab es auch ein Verfassungsgericht, was das Supreme Court hat da ja auch Grenzen gestellt, so geht es nicht weiter, diese Richtung, hier sind die Grenzen. Und die haben sich da einfach 20 Jahre genommen, um das Verfassungsgericht kaputt zu machen.
Indem sie einfach Leute platziert haben.
Leute platziert haben, die unvernünftig sind. Und das wird hier auch passieren, wenn hier ausreichend CDU, FDP an der Macht sind und wenn hier ausreichend die Bevölkerung in Mehrheit blöde Dinger will, dann wird sie irgendwann, wenn über Jahrzehnte hinweg die falschen Leute da an der Macht sind, werden sie irgendwann das auch bekommen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Gefahr, der man sich bewusst sein muss.
Man muss sich schon realisieren, dass man hier hängt am letzter Bremse. Man hängt hier alle Kabel der Fahrstuhl sind kaputt und man hängt hier an der Bremse.
Verfassungsgericht.
Verfassungsgericht, der letzte, was auch vom Gesetz her als letzter Schutz vorgesehen ist. Wenn mal alles nicht in Ordnung ist und wenn mal sogar die Regierung falsche Sachen will und das Parlament das unterstützt, dann gibt es noch das der Verfassung. Aber das ist schon letzte Bremse. Das muss man sich schon realisieren. Da muss man nicht leicht darüber denken, naja, ist jetzt alles in Ordnung. Und der Fahrstuhl ist jetzt echt kaputt und muss repariert worden. Und da muss ein neuer Kabel ran. Und das muss alles noch mal neu. Aber wie gesagt, wir sind noch da. Wir haben den Krieg nicht verloren. Das habe ich auch später im Blog noch geschrieben, dass ich mich nicht realisiert hatte, dass man so gewinnen kann, dass wir nicht die Mehrheit überzeugen mussten in Deutschland und dass es auch solche Länder gibt. Aber ja, ich glaube, wir sind, auch wenn wir hier noch heile rauskommen, und das können wir erst in vielleicht zehn Jahren feststellen, auch wenn wir hier heile rauskommen, dann sind wir ganz nah dran vorbeigegangen. Dann sind wir am totalitären Überwachungsstaat sind wir ganz, ganz nah dran vorbeigekommen. Und haben wir echt Glück gehabt, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt vier und dann vielleicht sechs, sieben, acht Mal die richtige Sache, die richtige Entscheidung getroffen hat. Gegen Popular Opinion, gegen Regierung, gegen Parlament hinein hinaus. Und das ist eigentlich kaum fassbar. Das hat geklappt. Das Grundgesetz, was ihr dann nach dem Krieg bekommen habt, hat dann funktioniert, kann man sagen.
Da muss man erst mal richtig böse sein, bevor man die richtige Marschroute einschlägt.
Ja, aber das war nicht gegeben. Gerade Anfang 2000 war das nicht gegeben, dass das passieren würde. Das war eher unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, muss man abwarten. Ich hatte so den Eindruck, dass die Thematisierung, die ja auch, sagen wir mal, die Thematisierung in eurem Vortrag war ja insofern auch hilfreich, als dass sie sich ja auch gegen so eine gewisse Illusion der Szene selbst eigentlich gerichtet hat, die sich dann ja auch teilweise für so ein bisschen unschlagbar hält und...
Ja, wir sind die Robin Hoods.
Also, so eine Überheblichkeit, die da mit...
Aber die Rest der Welt hat das auch wirklich auf dem, hat ein Bild von uns, wobei wir können das alles mit totalitären, totalitären Bewachungsstaaten, können wir so ein bisschen tolerieren, weil wenn das alles passiert, dann werden die Hacker uns schon retten. Die werden dann schon die Datenbanken platt machen und dann, wenn das alles mal aus dem Ruder läuft, dann werden die Hacker uns schon retten. Das ist wirklich ein Bild, was echt viele Leute haben. Und was wir auch selber geprägt haben. Wir sind ja so genial, wir können ja alles wohl kaputt machen und es gibt keine Sicherheit gegen uns, wir sind unendlich stark. Das haben wir selber geprägt und wir sind also selber Schuld daran, dass die Leute sich nicht realisieren, wie gefährlich das alles da draußen sein kann. Mit Überwachungsstaat und mit... Wir sind da selber schuld, dass die Leute glauben, wir können das doch immer kaputt machen mit so... Pam, wir machen einfach mal ein paar Hecks und ein paar Dinger und dann ist das alles wieder weg.
Kann man einfach alles wegzaubern. Aber ist nicht so.
Nee, ist nicht so. Und das muss man also auch die Leute klar vermitteln. Ich habe da immer auch schon viel früher gesagt, dieses Robin Hood Image hat diese gefährliche Seite, dass die Leute glauben, sie müssen selber nichts machen. Sie brauchen nicht drüber nachzudenken, weil die echte Gefährden, die echte Probleme, die können wir ja beheben. Dafür sind wir ja da.
Also sowohl eine Selbstüberschätzung als eben auch eine Überschätzung von außen, die hier zusammenkommt.
Ja, Privacy, guck mal, wer jetzt noch Privacy haben will, muss sich schon echt überlegen, dass es mal Insel gab, wo kein Privacy war und ein Mehr an Privacy, das ist mittlerweile umgekehrt. Es war mal so, dass internationale Telefongespräche, da würde mal abgehört und man musste ja nicht selber Verdacht, Großkriminalität haben, weil dann würde man auch abgehört. Aber weiter war eigentlich alles, überall anders hatte man seine Privacy. Mittlerweile ist es so, dass man sich echt überlegen muss, setze ich Tor ein, mache ich mein Mail über PGP und, und, und, und, und? Und wenn nicht, dann habe ich halt kein Privacy. Also die Insel sind jetzt Privacy und der großen See da draußen, das große Meer da draußen, ist kein Privacy, ist Überwachung oder zumindest Überwachbarkeit im Nachhinein. Und das hat sich in die letzten 10, 15 Jahre langsam Schritt vor Schritt geändert.
Aber nichtdestotrotz kann man ja gewisse Dinge, ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal so zurückschaut, wo bist du eingestiegen? Also auch Anfang der 80er Jahre, jetzt ZZC wird jetzt 2011 auch offiziell 30 Jahre alt. Also eigentlich reden wir jetzt von drei Jahrzehnten Hackerkultur in Europa. Ich denke, das kann man so nennen. Wie bewertest du diese Bewegung über diese Zeit? Was denkst du hat sich da herausgebildet? Inwieweit ist das sozusagen auch repräsentativ für eine neue Gesellschaft? Wir haben ja vorhin schon angesprochen, so wie die Hacker frühzeitig die Themen sich schon erarbeitet haben, hat sich dann immer fünf Jahre später oder manchmal auch nur zehn Jahre, eben erst zehn Jahre später, haben sich eigentlich dieselben Themen dann auf einmal in der Öffentlichkeit gefunden. Das war jetzt nicht nur bei Peak Oil so, das ist generell natürlich Netze, Computer, Einsatz etc. Die Gefahr von Privatsphäre, die Gefahr von Überwachung durch eben ausgefeiltere Technologien etc. Also diese ganze Komplexchancen und Risiken, da ist ja so eine Kultur in dieser Szene, diese Dinge dann eben auch frühzeitig auseinanderzunehmen, zu thematisieren, teilweise eben auch schon irgendwie zu leben, vorzuleben oder auch zu warnen. Und dann steht man da so mit seinem Schild und alle fragen sich, wovon redet ihr eigentlich? Aber was so im Rückblick, wie bewertest du den Erfolg oder den Lauf? Also was steckt da drin? Was ist sozusagen das Wesen und Wert dieser Bewegung über die Zeit?
Also ich glaube, die Wert ist groß, allgemein groß. Es gibt viel, wie gesagt, wir haben viel Einfluss gehabt, wir haben immer noch viel Einfluss und wir haben die Themen halt früher angebracht als alle anderen auch. Ja, das ist natürlich wichtig, weil das bringt der Gesellschaft Zeit, darüber nachzudenken. Das bringt die Gesellschaft Zeit, sich vorzubereiten und es nicht irgendwie sich überfallen zu lassen. Ich glaube, das Wichtigste, was wir gemacht haben, ist zu zeigen, es gibt innerhalb dieses Themenbereich Technik, gibt es Auswahl. Dieses Themenbereich ist nicht eine Tsunami, es ist nicht ein Ding, was über uns rollt und wo es innerhalb dieser Dinge keine Auswahl gibt. Wir müssen mit der Technik mit. Der Technik ist nicht ein eindeutiges Ding, was uns in eine Richtung schieben will, sondern wir haben innerhalb dieser Technik Auswahl und wie wir die Architektur schaffen. Architektur ist Politik. Wie wir diese Architektur schaffen, bestimmt, was für Welt wir in zehn Jahren haben. Dieses Verständnis, diese Gedanke ist, glaube ich, von uns getrieben worden. Diese Gedanke hat dafür gesorgt, an viele Stellen und viele auch nicht, hat an viele Stellen dafür gesorgt, dass wir auch die Architektur mitbestimmt haben. Dass sich Leute Gedanken gemacht haben, bevor es über sie rollte. Bevor es da war, dass sie, nee, wir wollen das diese Richtung lang haben oder diese Richtung lang, wir wollen die Technik so bauen und nicht so. Ich glaube, das ist unheimlich wichtig, weil die Technik in zunehmender Maße ist eigentlich unsere Umgebung. Die Technik ist, wo wir sind. Die Technik ist, wo wir uns äußern. Die Technik ist, wie wir uns äußern. Mit wem wir uns äußern ist unsere Infrastruktur genauso wie die Städte und die Geografie unsere Infrastruktur sind.
So bestimmt dann die Informationsinfrastruktur, die Informationsarchitektur sozusagen den Wert der Freiheit. Und wo geht es hin? Was steht jetzt sozusagen an? Ich meine jetzt, wo der Krieg doch noch nicht so ganz verloren wurde, sondern man vielleicht dann doch eben vielleicht nur eine Serie von Niederlagen hat einstecken müssen die schon so fast die weiße Fahne hat herausholen lassen.
Auch We Lost the World war nicht eine weiße Fahne. Es war eine Herausforderung. Wir haben gesagt, es geht weiter, nur ihr müsst euch gut überlegen, was zu kämpfen wert ist. Wir haben halt festgestellt, es gibt viele Menschen, die machen dieser Streit eine Weile und sind dann müde und sehen nur Verluste und wollen nicht mehr. Und man muss sich schon überlegen, sich Fights auszusuchen, die man auch irgendwie gewinnen kann. Auch wenn das nur Teilbereiche sind, man muss sich überlegen, was kann ich gewinnen. Deswegen war das mit dem Wahlcomputer auch so wichtig. Mir war das zumindest wichtig, ich will mal gewinnen. Ich habe keine Lust, mich irgendwie um groß allgemein Privacy und Sicherheit zu kümmern und da nur Verluste entgegenzunehmen. Ich will mal ein Thema, was überschaubar ist, und das war auch noch größer, als ich jemals gedacht habe, aber ich will ein Thema, was überschaubar ist und was wir gewinnen können. Und ich will eigentlich nur noch, dass wir uns so auslegen, dass wir gewinnen. Weil ich sah einfach um mich herum Leute nach zwei, drei Jahren müde, die Streit niederlegen, weil sie einfach nicht mehr weiter konnten, weil es nur Verluste, nur Schlimmer, nur Schlechter. Also es war auch eine Herausforderung, such dich Dinge, die du gewinnen kannst und bereite dich vor auf eine Welt, wobei es vielleicht Privacy nicht mehr gibt. Wobei Privacy ein Ding aus der Vergangenheit ist, zumindest Privacy, so wie wir es jetzt kennen. Ich meine, jetzt kennen Leute Privacy als eine Serie von Häkchen, die man bei Facebook setzen kann. Und das ist zwar eine Art von Privacy, aber es ist nicht die Privacy im absoluten Sinne, dass wenn ich mir mit jemandem einen Kaffee verabrede, dass das Gespräch eigentlich nur bei uns ist. So eine Art von Privacy ist es nicht, sondern es ist eine Art von Privacy, wobei man einer große US-Firma damit vertraut, bestimmte Sachen nur an bestimmte Leute weiter zu erzählen. Und das ist schon ein anderer Ansatz und ich befürchte, es entwickelt sich noch viel mehr in diese Richtung hinein. Es bewegt sich noch viel mehr in die Richtung von, alle machen ihre Dokumente bei Google Docs und machen Kalender bei Google Calendar.
Na ja, aber in gewisser Hinsicht, das wollten wir ja auch. Ich meine, wir wollten ja auch eine Gesellschaft in der Öffentlichkeit und wir wollten ja auch eine…
Ja, aber doch nicht deine eigene Dokumente in der Öffentlichkeit und deine E-Mail in der Öffentlichkeit.
Nein, nein, das meine ich ja auch gar nicht. Aber es ist ja schwierig. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite will man Kollaboration, man will irgendwie offenen Austausch, man irgendwie Informationstransparenz, man will eben auch offene Kommunikationssysteme verfügen. Man muss damit umgehen und muss sie auch erlernen.
Ich verstehe Firmen, die jetzt auf Google Docs umstellen, ganz gut, weil die haben jetzt eine Windows Server 2003 oder irgendwas, zahlen einen Trottel dafür, dass das alles am Laufen bleibt, nur damit sie Kalender und irgendwelche Dokumente teilen können mit 10, 20 Leuten. Zahlen dafür Unmengen Geld und können das alles von einem auf den anderen Tag auf Google Documents machen und sind dann froh und happy und haben E-Mail und Kalender zusammen und alles. Ja klar, macht das Sinn. Wenn es meine Firma wäre, würde ich mir auch überlegen. Wenn ich da das alles über Google Docs zu machen. Aber trotzdem hätte ich gerne, dass das alles lokal bei mir verschlüsselt wird. Und trotzdem hätte ich gerne, dass das nicht im Klartext bei Facebook und Google und alle diese Firmen liegt. Weil die Amerikaner haben mal keine Privacy Gesetze. Haben da mal do what thou wilt shall be the whole of the law als Privacy Gesetze verkauft, was ihr verkaufen könnt und deren Wirtschaft ist ja im Eimer. Die haben am Ende nicht viel mehr als Copyright und dass sie die Daten von allen haben, als die Dinge, um Geld mit zu verdienen.
Ich wollte was anderes hinaus, nämlich, was ich auch vor einigen Ausgaben im CAAE ein bisschen breiter diskutieren lassen, dass sich ja sozusagen jetzt auch eine neue Generation entwickelt, die eben auch diese Öffentlichkeit eben auch bewusst lebt. Nicht sagen wir mal jetzt auch bei diesem Begriff Privatsphäre jetzt nicht immer nur so, wie wir das jetzt so aus den 80er Jahren heraus mitgebracht haben. So könnte man es nennen. Ja, also die sagen wir mal ja auch so einen gewissen Charme darin sieht oder weniger ein Problem damit hat, die einfach ihre, wo die Grenze dieser, wo dieses Private anfängt, einfach woanders liegt, wo man das vielleicht vorher so noch nicht gehabt hat. Vorher möchte man, dass irgendwie alles geheim bleibt so und in dem Moment, wo ich vielleicht mal ein Plakat anziehe, das dort hängen, da ist was anderes.
Das ist auch ein temporäres Ding aus der Sicht, dass das jetzt auch die Personal-Funktionäre langsam aus der Facebook-Generation stammen und sich auch mal angucken, was bist du denn für einer. Und dass du dieses Idee, man könnte das ganze persönlich und wo man auf der Party war und dass man mal einen Kater hat und das ist alles mal im Netz zu seinem weiten Freund und Friend zu Friend und Friend zu Friend zu Friend, dass die alle wissen, dass du einen Kater hast gerade heute, dass das kein Problem ist, dass da dauert so lange, die Personal-Funktionäre alle noch nicht aus der Facebook-Generation stammen und du halt diese Conspiracy von wir sind ja alle 23 und 25 und können uns das untereinander leisten, dass wir wissen voneinander, dass wir Kater haben, dass ich halt deine Friend of a Friend, wo ich mal eine Nachricht dazu geschrieben hatte, hat heute einen Kater, dass ich das jetzt weiß, obwohl ich diese Person gar nicht kenne, das wird auch irgendwann wieder enden, weil das hat halt zu viele Nachteile. Die Firmen fangen jetzt an, die Leute zu befördern, die nicht mit 40 über irgendwelche Gesundheitsprobleme twittern, die Leute irgendwie in der Firma weiter vorauszubringen, die nicht irgendwie twittern, dass sie gerade beim Arzt waren und die nicht twittern, dass sie... Klar fangen die Firmen damit an, würdest du auch tun. Wahnsinnig. Na ja, wenn du...
Also ich habe auch schon andere Einstellungen gehört, die auch... Das will ich jetzt nicht so sehr vertiefen, aber die auch, sagen wir mal, die diesen Weg auch in so weit mitgehen, als dass das ja auch irgendwann die Normalität prägt. Ja, dass es prägen kann. Also ich sage nicht, so wird es sein und ich will auch gar nicht sagen, dass es jetzt ein gut oder schlecht...
Ja, aber dafür sind die wirtschaftlichen Impulse doch viel zu groß. Wenn du eine Firma mit 20 Mitarbeiter betreibst, dann hast du doch einen riesen wirtschaftlichen Impuls, da gesunde Leute ohne Karte...
Ja gut, es steht da aber auch ein Interesse daran, irgendwie glückliche, ausgeglichene und sozial aktive Menschen zu haben. Und ich habe auch ein Interesse daran, dass ich eine Mixtur, nicht nur eine Monokultur von Gesundheitsfanatikern habe, weil ich halt auch denke, dass das eine gute Sache sein kann. Also ich kann nicht beurteilen oder bewerten, was jetzt die Mehrheit der Firmen oder der Personalchefs jetzt tatsächlich denkt. Ich sage mir nur, für mich ist jetzt die Konsequenz nicht zwangsläufig.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass dieses alles im Netz werfen und alles auf Facebook werfen, dass das zumindest teilweise ist das eine Phase.
Das wird sicherlich auch wieder zurückgehen. Es ist halt auch rein ausprobieren. Ich meine, so wie wir früher auch alles exzessiv ausprobiert haben und es nicht unbedingt die Normalität darstellt und diese 18 Stunden und länger Hack-Sessions haben sich bei uns jetzt auch nicht gerade so eingespielt, dass wir das nur noch machen. Bleiben wir vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen auch bei dieser politischen Komponente der Hacker-Szene. Du hast das ja vorhin schon angedeutet, Julian Assange beim Kongress, der ja im letzten Jahr vor allem deswegen dabei war, um diese Initiative in Island vorzustellen, die ja mittlerweile auch glaube ich schon umgesetzt wird oder zumindest beschlossen worden ist, dass das umgesetzt werden soll, also quasi Datenfreihafen Island. Bevor wir vielleicht darauf im Detail kommen, du hast dich ja auch bei dem Wikileaks-Projekt ein bisschen mit eingebracht. Wie bewertest du das Projekt und was darum? Vielleicht kannst du ja mal sagen, inwiefern du dich da eingebracht hast und wie du das bewertest.
Also ich habe Anfang des Jahres mitgeholfen, dieses IMI, Icelandic Modern Media Initiative Gesetzesvorschlag oder dieses Parliamentary Initiative, war es eigentlich, mitzuschreiben. War dann zwei Wochen in Reykjavík und habe mit sowohl Leute von Wikileaks als Leute aus dem islandischen politischen Leben, Parlamentsmitglied, ein paar Aktivisten zusammen, haben wir das IMI geschrieben. Damals noch nicht als Wikileaks-Aktivist, sondern als unabhängig dazugeholt, weil ich Julien gut kannte. Schon länger kannte? Ja, schon länger kannte. Und Sommer 2009, mit denen zusammen auch in Malaysia unterwegs war, wegen dieses Hack in the Box-Kongress, da haben wir zusammen gesprochen. Also nacheinander über andere Sachen, aber wir waren da zusammen als Sprecher eingeladet. Und dann auch so ein bisschen rumgereist bin in Asien. Dann kam Sommer dieses Jahres und dieser Collateral-Murder-Film.
Also dieser veröffentlichte Mitschnitt aus dem US-Armee-Hubschrauber, wo da unter anderem Reuters-Journalist mit erschossen wurde.
Genau. Und da habe ich dann im Vorfeld davon mitbekommen, dass es da ein paar Probleme gab. Da gab es Twitters von Julien, die ein bisschen komisch waren. Da waren so Probleme, auch organisatorisch. Und dann habe ich eigentlich von einem auf den anderen Moment alles fallen lassen und morgens um 10 mich entschieden, dass ich nach Reykjavik ging, war dann mittags schon im Flieger und habe mich impulsiv da zwei Wochen mit beschäftigt, haben dann diesen Film fertig gemacht, die Pressekonferenz in Washington organisiert, da wo Julien dann das alles präsentiert hat. Ja und bin dann wieder gegangen. Also ich war nie ein Wikileaks-Volontär, der da Tag in Tag aus Dokumente bewertet hat oder so. Aber habe da als Freiwilliger halt mal geholfen, das alles auf die Beine zu stellen, um den Film und um diesen Öffentlichkeit. Das war der Durchbruch von Wikileaks in den Rest der Welt, sagen wir mal. Wikileaks war da schon bekannt, da gab es schon eine Menge Stories.
Also es war der mediale Durchbruch.
Der mediale Durchbruch in so Mainstream-Massenmedien, Breaking News, größte News der Welt, Durchbruch.
Trotzdem war ja gerade diese Publikation von Collateral Murder auch ein gewisser Hinsicht ein Wechsel der Strategie oder des Auftretens von Wikileaks. Bis dahin hatte man sich ja vor allem als Lieferant von Rohdaten positioniert. Es ging halt darum, generell eine Plattform zu sein, über die eben anonym Material veröffentlicht werden kann, was eben so sonst vielleicht nicht das Licht der Öffentlichkeit erblickt hätte, weil eben dann eine Person, eine Quelle daran hängt. Da war ja nun bei dieser Collateral Murder-Geschichte einiges anders. Erstens wurde ja das Video veröffentlicht, kommentiert, aufbereitet auf einer eigenen Webseite, wo auch Wikileaks quasi mit drauf stand, sowohl auf der Webseite als eben auch auf dem Video, sodass man ja eigentlich an der Stelle sehr viel mehr schon redaktionellen Charakter hatte, als dass es sich jetzt hier nur um das Veröffentlichen eines Videos handelt. Das hat eine Menge Kritik eingefahren, wie ich denke auch zu Recht. Insofern als das zunächst einmal dem widersprach, wie man sich selbst dargestellt hat. Wie siehst du das?
Ich glaube, teilweise war das zumindest bei Julien der Frustration, dass es die Medien manchmal nicht richtig machten. Ich glaube, er und ich glaube, wir alle waren auch echt richtig böse über dieses Video. Noch nicht mal so sehr diese Reuters-Journalisten, die erschossen würden. Das kann man noch als, naja, war ist hell, passiert mal was falsches. Sondern diese Leute, diese Bürger, die dann in diesem Auto kommen, um diese Verletzte abzuholen und die dann nochmal völlig erschossen worden. Und diese Witze, die diese Soldaten darüber machen, woran man sehr deutlich wahrnimmt, dies ist für diese Leute, die haben gerade sehr deutlich Bürger, die sehr deutlich nur da waren, um Verletzte abzuholen, komplett erschossen. Und es ist sehr klar, das ist für die just another day at the office. Dieses Kriegsverbrechen ist für dich, was hast du heute noch gemacht? So sehr deutlich Witze darüber machen. I think he just drove over a body. Das war für uns so, hier muss mal gezeigt werden, wie das wirklich ist da draußen. Und der Angst, dass das von der Presse nicht richtig gemacht würde, dass das dann nicht wirklich so diese Aufmerksamkeit bekommen würde, war, glaube ich, Antrieb für dieses Video. Es hat auch Kritik bekommen und teilweise ja auch zurecht. Und deswegen würde es auch nächstes Mal anders gemacht. Der nächste Veröffentlichung war dann ja auch zusammen mit Spiegel, Guardian, New York Times und war nicht mehr Wikileaks präsentiert, sondern die ganze Presse der Welt präsentiert. Und das ist auch teilweise zurecht. Und das könnte man auch mit so einem großen Datenhaufen, wie danach gekommen ist, könnte man das auch gar nicht mehr in diesen Formen machen. Aber gerade dieses Video hat so deutlich gemacht, wie sehr wir schon vom Propaganda geprägt sind. Die Propaganda ist ja immer, wir wollen da das Gute tun und das Land aufbauen. Und diese Bösen schießen ja immer auf uns und bringen Leute um. Und wir sind da ja nur, um das Land besser zu machen. Und zu zeigen, das ist ja ein Krieg. Und im Krieg machen beide Seiten total üble Sachen. Und da kann man gar nicht mehr von Guten und Schlechten reden, weil der Krieg ist diesen Punkt, wenn es schon das mal gegeben hat, ist es dieses Punkt schon langst vorbei. Und das mal deutlich auf den Punkt zu bringen, war glaube ich wichtig. Und das musste, glaube ich, auch in diesem Form gemacht worden.
Aber trotzdem muss man ja sagen, zielt sich Wikileaks dann sozusagen aus dieser Reihen, wir bewerten das alles neutral und wir würden jede Information veröffentlichen, wie es ja im Vorfeld immer postuliert wurde, eigentlich deutlich verabschiedet. In dem Moment, wo man dann auch ganz klar Stellung bezieht und sagt, wir müssen jetzt hier möglichst viele Dokumente zum Afghanistan-Krieg veröffentlichen, weil wir sind ja dagegen. Damit macht man sich natürlich auf eine Art und Weise auch angreifbar.
Das ist schon die Gegendarstellung, ist schon so. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das Wikileaks selber so sagt oder so präsentiert oder dass das auch so ist. Ich bin selber nicht Wikileaks, ich bin kein Wikileaks-Sprecher und ich nehme schon ein halbes Jahr überhaupt keine Interviews mehr, Anfragen mehr über Wikileaks, weil ich ja nicht drin bin und auch nicht im Namen von Wikileaks reden kann. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das so ist. Wikileaks sagt, wir brauchen, gerade wo es wichtig ist, und Krieg ist wichtig, gerade wo es wichtig ist, brauchen wir die Information, um bessere Entscheidungen treffen zu können. Und nicht wir sind gegen diesen Krieg, sondern es gibt so wenig Information über, was da wirklich abgeht, dass wir unsere Entscheidungen über diesen Krieg nicht vertrauen können. Das ist die Wikileaks und nicht wir sind dagegen und deswegen müssen wir selber Aktivismus treiben, sondern hier sind die Rohdaten. Gerade die Rohdaten und nicht irgendwie eine Aufbereitung. Hier ist es roh, was da abgeht und macht da euer Ding raus. Und deswegen machen das jetzt auch The Guardian und New York Times. Da glaube ich nicht, dass das eine Verabschiedung von Neutralität ist. Sowieso glaube ich nicht so sehr an Neutralität.
Jeder hat so seine Agenda.
Ja, aber Wikileaks hat ja auch diese Climate Gate E-Mails veröffentlicht, was eigentlich die ganze Klima-Gipfel, wo ich auch war, im Kopenhagen komplett entgleist hat, hat Wikileaks auch veröffentlicht. Nicht, weil sie dachten, da ist jetzt ein Komplott drin, sondern das hier ist gerade wichtig. Das hier ist gerade Information, die wahr ist und die zeigt, was da im Feld wirklich passiert. Auch wenn es nicht das Komplott ist. Und das hat Julien sogar auch öffentlich gesagt. Wir sehen dieses Komplott, was diese ganze Climate Denier sehen, sehen wir nicht so. Wenn wir das analysieren, dann sind das halt Menschen, die Julien hat da schon entschärft oder zumindest das versucht, was natürlich dann am Ende nicht geht, wenn solche Informationen so brisant rauskommt.
Es gab ja so eine ähnliche Initiative, wenn auch nur sehr abgeschwächt und beileibe nicht so erfolgreich und so stringent durchgezogen. Zum Beispiel beim Club gab es irgendwann mal auch so, wie hieß es, gelöschte Dokumente. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau. Also so die Idee, so eine Plattform zu schaffen, geisterte ja eigentlich schon länger rum. Ich weiß es jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr. Wie auch immer, spielt ja eigentlich auch gar keine besondere Rolle. Was ich sozusagen jetzt nochmal in Kontext stellen wollte, ist, wie siehst du das Verhältnis von so einem Projekt wie Wikileaks zu der Hacker-Bewegung? Denkst du, dass das ein Teil davon ist? Ist das was ganz anderes? Ist das schon so eine Art Auswirkung davon?
Es ist deutlich, dass Wikileaks aus unserer Gedankenwelt kommt. Wikileaks ist von Hacker gegründet worden. Wikileaks hat diese Gedankenwelt mit wir brauchen Transparenz. Aber Wikileaks ist eher ein Projekt aus Unfrieden mit Medien, mit wie die Medien im Moment funktionieren. Und das ist einer unserer Themen, aber nicht das zentrale Thema. Aber Wikileaks kommt eher aus dieser Unfriede mit the corporate media als aus was anderes. Und manche reagieren dadurch, dass sie dann selber Radiosendungen machen oder selber Media sind, weil sie die corporate media nicht gefällt. Anderen reagieren dadurch, dass sie versuchen, die corporate media auf eine ehrlichere Basis zu gestalten, dadurch, dass sie neue Materialien da reinwerfen oder neue Sichtweisen oder neue... Ich denke, beide sind wertvoll. Und ich glaube schon, dass da gerade so das Wikileaks... Wikileaks handelt sich ja auch um Geheime. Zum Beispiel das Geheim, wo kommen die Informationen dann her, wer ist Quelle? Und auf diese Ebene Geheime zu haben, das ist halt in dieser Welt nur noch Nachrichtendienste und Hacker vorbehalten. Also alles, was in der Zukunft um Geheime dreht und nicht mit Nachrichtendiensten zu tun hat, das sind wir. Da müssen wir uns halt dran gewohnen.
Was steht denn jetzt so an für die Hacker? Was siehst du denn als die kommenden Themenlagen, die sich jetzt abzeichnen? Muss sich überhaupt irgendwas ändern oder geht alles den richtigen Weg? Kann man das eh nicht sagen? Passiert das alles von alleine?
Also mein großes Thema, wo ich mich einlese und was mich interessiert, wo ich nicht genau weiß, was unsere Rolle sein wird, aber wir werden eine Rolle haben, ist, dass die Welt nicht ruhiger wird. Die Gedanke, es kommt jetzt wieder eine Periode von Ruhe. Wir hatten ja diesen Krach an der Börse, wir hatten dies und wir hatten jenes. Aber jetzt kommt wieder Ruhe. Es wird nicht wieder ruhig. Es wird unruhig bleiben. Und einiges wird auch echt kaputtgehen. Ich glaube, die Basisursachen für Kreditkrise, die Basisursachen für die Komplexität der finanziellen Produkte, die Geschwindigkeit der finanziellen Märkte, so alle diese grundlegenden Probleme, dieses Wollen, da eine Normalität herzustellen, damit Goldman Sachs wieder viel Geld verdienen kann, das hat sich alles nicht geändert. Es wird neues Geld dazugedrückt. Die Symptome werden irgendwie bekämpft, aber die Ursachen nicht. Und ich glaube, das läuft nochmal richtig aus dem Ruder. Und ich hätte gerne, dass die Hacker-Community dann so platziert ist, dass wir das maximal verstehen und irgendwie auch erklären können. Weil ich glaube wirklich, dass es nicht so viele anderen gibt, die das alles insgesamt noch erklären können. Vielleicht wir auch nicht, aber wir haben zumindest einen Teil der Erklärung. Und ich halte es vor wichtig, dass wir das dann irgendwie auch erzählen können, dass wir da irgendwie auch eine zusammenhängende Geschichte dazu haben. Auch mit, zum Beispiel, ich glaube, die Welt ist im Moment echt zu komplex. Was heißt, alle Systeme sind darauf angelegt, dass alle andere Systeme funktionieren. Sie ist nicht, sie ist brittle, zerbrechlich. Wenn du jetzt zehn Hammer brauchst, dann müssen sie quasi schon just in time aus irgendein Lager in Süddeutschland kommen. Und die Nagel kommen dann aus einem Lager in Polen. Alles just in time. Und wenn das alles mal zusammenbricht oder zumindest mal weniger funktioniert, dann läuft es viel weiter aus dem Ruder, als dass es alles etwas einfacher wäre. Was der Finanzwelt angeht, man müsste bestimmte Derivate, bestimmte Produkte einfach verbieten. Und zwar schnell. Weil ansonsten gefährdet man auch die realen Wirtschaft. Unglaublich. Und ich glaube, wir haben da ein Verständnis. Nicht, weil wir die wirtschaftlichen Experten sind, oder weil wir total in der Buchhaltung drin sind, aber einfach weil wir verstehen, wie das ist, wenn das alles dezentral und schnell wird. Zunahme an Dezentralität und Zunahme an Geschwindigkeit, das kennen wir schon eine Weile. Und wir haben schon instinktiv Gedanken darüber, was dann schief geht und wie das alles läuft. Und guck mal auf so etwas wie Feifesblock. Da ist eine Menge an Humor richtig gebracht. Und zwar irgendwie auch amusant. Aber schon eine Menge an Wissen, wie funktioniert die Welt da draußen dann richtig? Und das interessiert Hacker, glaube ich auch. Was steckt dann an Nachrichtendiensten oder an politischen Deals? Was steckt dann dahinter? Wir sind jetzt alle nicht mehr 17, einige von uns sind auch 30 und 40. Uns interessiert halt, wie Dinge funktionieren. Das begrenzt sich nicht auf Kernels.
Man sollte sich nicht nur um die Technik als solche kümmern, sondern auch die Gesellschaft in zunehmendem Maße als Hackobjekt verstehen?
Ja. Und auch einsehen, dass wir da einen Teil der Lösung haben. Auch wenn es nicht der Lösung ganz ist. Aber wir haben da einen Teil der Lösung, weil wir verstehen, wo es manchmal langgeht. Ich glaube wirklich, dass wir die kommenden 15 Jahre in der Welt noch sehr gravierende Änderungen sehen werden. Sehr, sehr gravierende Sachen werden sich ändern. Ich habe zum Beispiel, mit was ich so an Nachrichten zu mir komme, keine Ahnung, ob wir in 15 Jahren noch den Euro haben, ob das nicht auseinanderfliegt. Dann geht das Leben auch weiter, wenn das auseinanderfliegt. Aber dann werden noch mal Sachen vielleicht ein bisschen anders. Mein Ansatz ist, dass Leute einfach mal zu erzählen, dass das nicht alles so weitergehen braucht, dass das auch ganz anders sein kann. Ich merke, dass, wenn ich mit Leuten rede, über wie die Welt so funktioniert, dass viel Wissen, was ich habe, eher doch noch in unsere Subculture klebt. Dass das nicht so richtig rauskommt, so wie Peak Oil damals. Wir wissen alle davon. Wir haben das alles mal gelesen und die Zahlen gesehen und gedacht, ach du Scheiße. Aber alle da draußen haben so das Gefühl, was ist das denn für ein Thema? Und das Gefühl habe ich jetzt auch mit dieser, was passiert denn in der Wirtschaft? Oder was passiert mit Europa? Oder wie sieht die Zukunft aus? Klima? Was passiert in den nächsten 20, 30 Jahren? Ich glaube, dass wir da auch einfach eine größere Fantasie haben, was da an möglichen Szenarien alles passieren könnte.
Ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt weitergehen und sagen, man hat vielleicht auch noch eine größere Verantwortung. Was ich ja auch festgestellt habe, ist, selbst wenn Leute, selbst wenn sie die Zahlen haben, selbst wenn sie die Zahlen sehen, selbst wenn sie es erklärt bekommen, dass eigentlich auch viele es nicht unbedingt auch immer hören wollen. Und nicht unbedingt, weil da auch diese Masse an Veränderungen natürlich auch schon an sich bedrohlich daherkommt, weil man irgendwie, oh Gott, jetzt kommt schon wieder dieser Hacker und erzählt mir wieder, wie die Welt gleich morgen wieder auseinanderfällt. Das will ich jetzt gerade irgendwie nicht hören, weil dann kann ich irgendwie nicht über Kindergarten, Schule und meine Berufswahl nachdenken, wenn ich die ganze Zeit das Gefühl habe, in zehn Jahren stürzt alles ein. Und ich denke, dass sich dann viele Leute eben auch abwenden. Und das ist auch schon eine gewisse Kraft dazugehört, eben trotz solcher Drohszenarien, die sich auch so eine Analyse unter Umständen ableiten lassen, dann auch noch so die Gewissheit zu behalten. Okay, das sieht jetzt zwar alles bedrohlich aus, aber das muss jetzt auch nicht unbedingt der Untergang der Welt sein. Ich nehme mich dieser Realität jetzt trotzdem mal an und versuche mal darüber produktiv nachzudenken. Mir kreist die ganze Zeit so ein Begriff aus der Softwareentwicklung durch den Kopf, wo man ja auch dieses Problem hat, dass wenn man so ein System entwickelt hat und man schraubt dann immer dran rum, dass es dann immer an Komplexität zunimmt, die Abhängigkeiten untereinander immer weiter zunehmen. Und irgendwann wird das Ganze nicht mehr händelbar. Dann brechen einem noch zwei, drei Leute weg, die da ewig dran mit rumgeschraubt haben. Dann versteht man die Komplexität eben auch nicht mehr. Und wenn man dann eben nicht diesen Prozess des Refactorings, dieses ich nehme mir jetzt eine einzelne Komponente, schau, was sie eigentlich tun soll, guck, was ihre Instabilität ist und bau sie dann irgendwie neu, damit sie im Wesentlichen dieselbe Dienstleistung erbringt, aber eben stabiler vorhersagbarer und vielleicht eben auch wartbarer. Dass man so einen ähnlichen Prozess vielleicht auch an die Gesellschaft anlegen sollte. Und dass das vielleicht eine Aufgabe sein könnte für die Hacker sozusagen, so ein Refactoring der Gesellschaft.
Das ist genau, was ich meinte mit dieser Vereinfachung. Wir brauchen eine Menge unnötige Komplexität und nicht mehr Verständlichkeit, Prozesse aus der Gesellschaft rauszunehmen. Das muss das Thema der nächsten 10, 20 Jahre sein.
Ja, Rob, ich denke, an der Stelle können wir das dann auch zu einem Ende führen, unser nettes Gespräch.
Ja, war gut, ne?
Wir haben auf jeden Fall eine Menge auf den Tisch gelegt. Da muss man jetzt erst mal drüber nachdenken. Muss ich auch noch mal ein bisschen drüber nachdenken. Müsst ihr dann auch mal alle drüber nachdenken, ihr, die ihr jetzt hier durchgehalten habt, fast wieder drei Stunden. Da kommt immer ganz schön was zusammen, wenn man erst mal anfängt, ein bisschen zu diskutieren. Aber das war jetzt auch mal ein wichtiger Rückblick. Mir brannte es auch lange Zeit auf den Nägeln, auch mal so diese spezifische holländische Perspektive hier auch mal mit aufzunehmen, was ja auch schon so ein paar andere Chaos-Radio-Express-Folgen ergänzt, wo ich versucht habe, so diese alte Zeit auch noch mal so ein bisschen zu reflektieren. Die eine habe ich ja schon genannt, die 100. Ausgabe. Wer es noch nicht gehört hat, in dem Zusammenhang gibt es ja auch die schöne Sendung Tuva TXT, Ausgabe Nummer 77, die so in diesen Gründungsmythos vom Club mit reingeht. Und auch zuletzt, gerade wo wir vorhin noch über diese BTX-Geschichte, also sozusagen dieser Urhack des CCC gesprochen haben, da hatte ich ja neulich die Livesendung in Linz auf der AS Elektronica mit Vic und Andreas Lehner über CCC und eben auch dieses Verhältnis zu der Öffentlichkeit, Chaos Radio Express 161. Und jetzt haben wir wieder eine Sendung. Wird aber sicherlich auch nicht die letzte sein. Gut, jetzt halte ich aber auch das Maul. Vielen Dank, Rob.
Gerne, gut Spaß gemacht.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.